foreign everybody I'm going to open this
subcommittee work session for hb221
relative to the acquisition of
agricultural land development rights
so we are here this morning
to clarify
what this bill
intends to do
and how we may
accomplish what we need to do to solve a
problem
that is I guess apparent
so uh
representative Bixby do you have some
comments sure
each point of this bill is to make it
easier to preserve agricultural land in
New Hampshire please use your
um yes okay so the the key point of this
bill is to make it easier to preserve
agricultural land in New Hampshire and
uh we have on in our statutes a land
present an agricultural land
preservation program that was developed
in the 1980s and at the point when it
was developed uh the American Farmland
trust was barely coming into existence
The Nature Conservancy was ignoring
agricultural land and uh there were a
number of other
um
and land preservation preserving
organizations that hadn't even thought
about organizing yet uh and uh so uh a
lot of the language in this re reflects
the methods that were available in the
1980s for preserving agricultural land
as opposed to what is now
um available which is much more robust
and uh it has uh one of the things that
uh was the case in the 1980s was that
the in New Hampshire the Department of
Agriculture was pretty much the only
game in town preserving agricultural
land uh and now there are many
organizations which are doing that are
actually in many ways better suited to
doing that than the department but on
being able to cooperate with the
Department strength would strengthen
their uh their programs as well so
what this bill the main purpose is that
this bill is to make it easier for other
land preservation programs that are
interested in working with agricultural
land preserve uh and work with the
Department to preserve land and get rid
of the impediments and statute that make
that harder uh and I'm going to ask uh
I'm not
um which one of you uh Jeremy are you
the best person to talk to this okay so
I'm going to ask Jeremy Lucci to come up
and explain uh how the proposed
amendment that you have before you would
do the job that needs to be done
Mr Lucci you are with Department of
Agriculture
oh okay thank you
sure yes
I have some prepared remarks and then
I'm really happy to answer any questions
you may have
so first of all thank you
Representatives Bigsby Kaplan and Aaron
for supporting this important bill
with a goal to amend the language of RSA
432 to provide the state of New
Hampshire with an ability to hold a
right of enforcement to the agricultural
land development rights rather than hold
the rights themselves
this flexibility will allow New
Hampshire's land trusts to use the Alp
available through the U.S Department of
agriculture's Natural Resources
conservation service agricultural
conservation easement program
the acronym is ASAP
ASAP provides critical assistance for
Farmland conservation in New Hampshire
but in order to leverage those federal
dollars effectively land trusts must
find matching dollars at the state and
local level
without these matching funds the federal
dollars go unspent
particularly in the wake of the upcoming
U.S farm bill which is predicted to
dramatically increase those Farmland
protection funds
so I just wanted to step back a little
bit and for those of you not well versed
in Farmland protection
I'd like to provide a few statistics
regarding Farmland in New Hampshire
and before I do so I'd respectfully ask
you a series of simple questions about
whether Farmland protection is a
important to your everyday life here in
New Hampshire
do you eat food and if so do you know
where that food comes from
are you certain that food will always be
available and if so what guarantees do
you have
if our International Food supply chain
were disrupted by drought flood war or
pandemic how would New Hampshire
citizens feed themselves
if New Hampshire doesn't protect its
remaining Farmland where will we turn
when the grocery stores shelves are
empty
from 1925 to 2008 New Hampshire lost 90
percent of its farmland
according to American Farmland trust New
Hampshire lost another 11 600 acres
of Farmland from 2001 to 2016.
and at this pace New Hampshire is
predicted to lose another 35 000 Acres
of Farmland by 2040. once lost that land
is almost never returned to use as a
farm
and here in New Hampshire more than five
times as many farmers are over the age
of 65 as under age 35 meaning that a
remaining Farmland will be extremely
susceptible to conversion over the next
15 to 25 years
land trusts like Southeast Land Trust
protect hundreds of Acres of Farmland in
New Hampshire each year
using programs like the federal ASAP
program when we protect Farmland we
often see that communities in New
Hampshire
with less financial resources are unable
to protect their Farms because it costs
too much
without a dedicated funding source for
Farmland protection at the state level
that's accessible to land trusts
less affluent communities often miss out
a loss not only for the farmer and the
municipality but for the State of New
Hampshire in general because we lose the
ability to feed ourselves in times of
need
with the proposed changes to House Bill
221 Land Trust will be able to use these
Alp funds to leverage the federal
funding programs and protect the last of
New Hampshire's Farmland before they are
lost forever
your next meal may depend on it
thank you for your time I'm happy to
answer any questions and I think you
already received a document from the New
Hampshire Food Alliance
discussing why this bill is important
Mr Lucci it is Lucci right yes yes thank
you so much for coming this morning and
helping us out to work through some
questions on this bill so the original
um draft of this proposed legislation
is sort of a one-line change to statute
are you talking about that that bill or
there's another document that has been
uh
distributed that has some other changes
in it is this the one that you're
speaking of or the original Bill yes so
the the original bill that was filed had
a very important change that would allow
the state to hold the right of
enforcement as opposed to the the
agricultural preservation restriction
itself
that is very important change but these
other changes that have been passed
around are also critical so that the New
Hampshire land trusts will be able to
work with federal agencies to leverage
those federal funds land trusts in New
Hampshire most of us are accredited by
the land trust Alliance and without
these additional changes we would not be
able to use these Alp funds so the
additional changes that were were shared
will allow us to do so
okay thank you any questions from the
rest of the committee subcommittee
representative
huh representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I actually have two ones very simple
can I have a copy of your written
remarks absolutely thank you
um and once Farmland is put it put into
a land trust are there any stipulations
to the farmers themselves on what the
use of that property can be
yes so uh when using the Alp funding
um there's a limitation on buildings
only agricultural buildings could be
constructed on the property and when
they're working with land trusts or with
any of the federal funds there's a two
percent limitation on the amount of
buildings covering uh that land so
essentially what it does is it it forces
the farmers to keep that Land open and
available for agriculture
when you say only two percent of
buildings on that property is that after
it's put into Land Trust because
um what if they needed to build a uh
like a processing plant or a processing
facility on that property to deal with
what they're producing would that and it
was over two percent so that would not
be able to be put on the property is
that the understanding yeah over two
percent would be an incredibly large
building so if you're talking about a
Hundred Acre Farm that'd be a two acre
eighty eighty thousand plus square foot
building so the two percent we've found
in all of our Farmland protection is is
adequate thank you yep
and so my question to you is
um what is considered agricultural use
would we be talking about
um well well why don't you explain what
what is what kind of buildings are
considered agricultural use so I realize
it's getting into the weeds a little bit
and every conservation easement is often
drafted a little bit differently but
when you're dealing with federal funds
which is one of the primary reasons
we're here so that we can leverage those
federal funds bring them back to New
Hampshire and help us protect some
Farmland
each land trust and the U.S department
of Agriculture decide how to define
agriculture most often we defer to the
state definition of agriculture
I don't have it in front of me but
um I think everyone is somewhat familiar
with what that definition is
so any kind of growing of food livestock
Horticultural products uh essentially
the the growing of agricultural products
on the property
would that cons would that include Farm
stands yes yep yep so if somebody wanted
to erect a small building to sell their
vegetables or their meat or something
that would be absolutely okay yeah we're
really focused you know the Farmland
protection has evolved over time as
representative Bixby mentioned a lot of
these rules are crafted in the 80s and
things have changed quite a bit since
then Farms have to be more Nimble and in
order for them to remain viable they
have to do things like a Farm Stand or a
farm store to sell their own products
directly to Consumers so modern day
Farmland protection
ease conservation easements are designed
to allow those types of things
thank you
representative Bixby yes so um one
um building issue that I could see uh
creating a little bit of confusion would
be
um a greenhouse space for uh either the
um
you know for doing uh Horticultural
plants or for doing uh you know starting
the plants then I go out to the field or
also Hydroponics uh which is a can be a
substantial food production uh and it
would that sort of building be limited
by uh the the types of grants that would
be available
so you know generally speaking
um that two percent and they call it an
impervious surface limitation but
essentially that's buildings
um that that is designed to protect what
we're really trying to do with Farmland
protection is protect the soils
not all soils are created equal and New
Hampshire only has a very limited amount
of soils that are going to be really
good at growing crops uh for to have
food for people so we're trying to
protect those soils and the two percent
limitation is meant to allow for certain
types of buildings
um like uh
you're referencing to grow seedlings to
maybe get the crops started we we feel
that the two percent limitation is
adequate for that type of production if
there's a say a Horticultural operation
that is growing everything under a roof
and in a very controlled environment
they don't really have a need for that
important Farmland soil and we would
rather focus on farms where we're
protecting the soil itself
those that are that are growing under
Greenhouse or a very controlled
environment they can essentially build
that Greenhouse wherever they'd like but
it it probably shouldn't be on on
Farmland important Farmland soils
thank you thank you
representative Howard you have a
question
I just have a question about the handout
that you sent that you passed out um is
the blue the only new change for in the
red is is what we were proposing before
oh I'm sorry yeah that that was just a
function of word on the day that we put
this together
um the only change that was
um was suggested initially is in 432-24
and searching for mine right now under
uh excuse me 432 uh 22
it's on the front page
under number Roman numeral two
that was the initials suggested change
and what that really does like I had
said before is that allows the state to
hold the right of enforcement so
essentially These funds would be
available for Farmland protection and
the state would hold a Perpetual right
to enforce the terms of the easement but
uniquely and I think uh better suited
for the Department
they wouldn't have to be out there every
year monitoring these conservation
easements which cost money and time and
expertise that's something that land
trusts already do and we would have to
do for all of the work we do with the
federal government when we use federal
funds so this allows to stay to hold
that right of enforcement without having
the burden of having to be out there
every year
follow up
um so the would the land trust Coalition
is that is that a state-based Corp um
organization yeah the New Hampshire land
trust Coalition is is a group of land
trusts around the state of New Hampshire
only within New Hampshire although some
of those actually what I should say is
some of those land trusts on the borders
like upper Saco Valley land trust or
Upper Valley land trusts they do work in
Vermont or Maine but the Coalition is
made up of new hampshire-based land
trusts
represent Bixby
um yeah so I'm wondering if we could uh
walk through some of the changes that
were not in the original bill
um and it looks like on the first page
uh you're suggesting that
um a member of the land trust Coalition
uh be added to the
um to the aop board uh and if you want
to speak to that briefly I can just say
very quickly you know as I've mentioned
um modern land conservation is is very
complex and Technical
um it's it's something that I think land
trusts do for a living and we feel like
it would be a very good idea for the
state to have a member of the landross
community on this board advising
particularly you know the the
administrative rules uh will need to be
gone through again they haven't been uh
Rewritten since the 80s or 90s so as I
go through those administrative rules we
want to make sure or someone from the
land trust Community is there and can
help ensure that there isn't any
conflict with the federal funding
sources that we're aiming to to use
before before we go a little further
into the proposed language can you tell
the subcommittee a little bit about
what are the problems that we're running
into now without having this legislation
I mean give an example of a of a recent
issue that something has happened yeah
yeah
because this is the Departments I think
perhaps I'm
better
poised to to respond to that okay she
wouldn't have any knowledge of things
that I
okay absolutely all right and I think is
because this is the work session we
might want to open it up to a little bit
more you know rather than a sort of the
testimony approach maybe having people
who have the the knowledge ship in so
maybe the yeah so sure uh commissioner
why don't you come up and and just give
us a brief explanation of a recent issue
that happened that because we don't have
this legislation
changed uh has happened so first of all
to be clear the department has not
purchased any development rights since
the 80s
since l-chip came into existence there's
been no funding for this program so all
the Deeds that we hold and there are 84
or something like that are all
go back many years now
recently in one one important issue
that's come up has been the issue of
solar
um and although it doesn't set a
precedent I'm very concerned about it
and and will probably be
um
perhaps even talking about
um some legislature in the future but we
hold a
development rights to a piece of of
property
where solar panels were placed on our
easement without permission
now
that really limits agricultural
production
in that case
the court found
that the production of electricity
was an agricultural use
we decided not to appeal that
because of the precedent it could
um
could make so we probably should be
looking at making sure because it's this
slippery slope the farm does get credits
when they produce too much and there's
no way for us to monitor any of that and
then how do we know you know what
happens if they they go out of business
and are still producing electricity and
just selling it into the grid this is a
real slippery slope so that's the most
recent
thing I did have one
um several years ago where there's a
small piece of land over on the Seacoast
area
and the owners decided Well it's not
suitable for agriculture anymore their
excuse was because it's surrounded by
too many
housing houses well that was the purpose
of buying the property and they said and
see we're just growing Christmas trees
on it and I said okay well that is an
agricultural use I'm not calling the
committee together
our language on extinguishment is really
odd land that is no longer suitable for
agricultural uses how does a land no
longer become suitable for agricultural
use as well if somebody polluted that a
neighbor polluted the land well it's not
really it becomes a super fun site I
would assume and would have to be
restored
so that's a very strange language it's
not acceptable
to uh to the USDA but
really right now there aren't a lot of
issues although we do have cleanup
issues that we need to deal with but the
land the language
um that we currently have is a problem
and it would really be problematic going
going forward and I would certainly say
that even without a change in law on
solar panels I would make sure that any
deed that we were involved with excluded
solar panels from being based on on the
ground roofs is fine I mean if you want
to put got a parking lot you want to put
them above parking lots fine they
shouldn't be taking agricultural land
out of production out of its highest and
best use
thank you
you have some comment back there
sure
to all these issues how many of you are
what I've learned is that the Alp
program that commissioner
has funds set aside for it but it's
essentially not functioning because it
resides within the department of
agricultural markets and food which
doesn't have the capacity right now to
administer it so those funds have not
been utilized at all since they become
allocated to this program
um and so they're just they're just
sitting in this change would enable us
to make use of those thoughts
continue to partnership with the theme
and so the changes are essential because
they make the pro they'll be able to
make the program function right now it
is not it is not I understand it
function and if I if I could further
clarify that
um and that is in part because realizing
um the limitations my original goal was
to partner with USDA because we're
leaving so much money sitting on the
table as I got into this realized that
we weren't going to be able to partner
with USDA or the land trusts without
statutory change how much in dollars
would you say is currently I believe I
have
the end of this fiscal year I think it
was it's like
one point
two five million there's another 250 per
year in the budget so we will be at 1.75
I believe
um which will allow us to make an impact
but we need these changes to take place
to bring all the partners into place and
frankly I do not want to see us add more
land that we can't properly Monitor and
don't have the staff to do that's
becoming an issue for all in a lot of
places because we keep adding Parcels of
land and we've got to figure out the
monitoring part of it but I don't want
to add staff to do that okay thank you
representative Bixby so that one point
uh
1.5 one point to become become 1.7
eventually million is money in the
department that is not able to be spent
right now and that would then be
available for a match with USDA funds
which means we're leaving another
million and a half on the table that we
could be bringing into the state to do
this but we're not is that correct
yeah and and if I could I would just add
on to that and um my colleague from
American Farmland trust could do this
but what's important to understand is
the amount of funding that's available
for this at the federal level is about
to dramatically increase so New
Hampshire would be essentially left in
the dust and unable to access those
funds unless we tweak this language so
Chelsea yeah
in addition to potentially seeing more
money go to the agricultural
conservation easement program in the
next Farm Bill Congress passed the
inflation reduction Act
earlier in early 20 or in mid-2022 and
that allocated over 20 billion dollars
to commemoration programs at USC and RTS
including 1.4 billion for the
agricultural conservation easement
program and so that is money that New
Hampshire could leverage if this program
is self-running
so is it possible for uh money from uh
like the Farmland trust or another uh
organ uh private organization to be used
to leverage those federal funds to
increase the amount that we could get
into New Hampshire
yeah so that's something we do with
nearly every one of those projects take
for example
um I'm working on a dairy farm in the
town of Greenland New Hampshire
um The Smiths own it and um it's a
project that l-chips supported but
l-chip you know is a very competitive
Grant process they only have enough
money to fund a few Farmland projects a
year
um I have probably 10 Farmland projects
on my desk right now that I'm struggling
to find funds for that would be a good
fit for this program so we're very land
trusts are very Nimble and used to
finding funds from lots of different
places to make these projects work
what's a real challenge in New Hampshire
as opposed to a lot of the other New
England states is we don't have a
dedicated Farmland protection fund other
states do that and they're protecting a
lot more Farmland than New Hampshire
representative Howard
if um if this passes would the land
trust be able to take over monitoring
the exist the lands already held by the
department of existing I believe the way
the statute reads is they can delegate
that to another organization and that
would really be up to the department
that's not something we'd necessarily
advocate for but we are we already have
easement monitors on staff they're
skilled at doing that and that's
something the department could certainly
consider
representative smart
so if the if the property is already in
a conservation easement and then this we
and this bill passes
how how is our is the existing
conservation easement already like does
the state come in and say okay now we're
in charge or how does that work no so
for the existing ones we are in charge
nothing will change for the existing
ones okay if in the future there was a
decision to farm out the monitoring that
would be totally different issue yeah we
really should be focusing on on
this this bill and what the language
allows us to do which is to allow us to
Simply to partner with the land trust
and the USDA we could still on our own
purchase Deeds strictly on on the terms
that exist
so we would not necessarily you know
we're not giving up our ability to do
anything this is an expansion of our
ability to access other other funds
which all along I thought we could
access USDA funds and then that's become
clear that without at least that part of
the change we can't do
can't do that because they are not they
are not okay with our extinguishment
clause in there and will not participate
without the language change that is
being proposed you know in uh
in 432-24
. so I am in full support of all of the
language here you know things have been
moving crazy I wish we'd gotten to the
point where this had been all done
before
um we had to have it drafted
unfortunately there's been too many
things uh moving and so a strong support
of this but please just
you know understand that all we are
doing here you know adding the land
trust Coalition I think that's important
right now the executive director of
l-chip is on the board as a public
member I think that's important I think
this will be a a key piece as well
um but this is just giving us more
opportunities it's not giving up any
rights that we have it's not giving up
any rights to what we hold and it
doesn't stop us from doing what we used
to do if there was the right
circumstance but you know the leveraging
of the money is critical for this I
wouldn't have come in and asked to
refund this if if there wasn't the
possibility to match funds
representative
thank you madam Sharon thank you
commissioner for being here
um
one well I have a couple of questions uh
one uh because we'll be partnering with
the USDA are there any strings going to
be attached to those federal dollars
no no not to the best of my knowledge
other than they would have if we were to
release and again I can't see any any
circumstances where that would happen
where that would be advantageous to to
release those but that's the only thing
um obviously they're going to decide
whether they want to participate in a
particular project
but um
you know in in terms of string our goals
are all the same to preserve farmland
Representatives come to a follow-up
thank you and my my other question is is
um you know I agree with you that if
we're going to put land into
you know a trust or whatever for
agricultural purposes that solar should
be excluded from that I agree hardly
with that
we're in here would we where would you
put that into language
that would be in the Deeds that every
deed is different you can't have because
each Farm is going to be different and
what they do and what the requirements
of the farm are going to be different so
the deed language doesn't belong in in
statute except for
the particulars that are already there
um and that's not what we're we're
talking about so I wasn't prepared to
talk about those those things but
things can be excluded or included in
the deed as long as they meet the
statutory requirements thank you yeah
and just to tag on to that
um when I mentioned that land trusts
used several different funding sources
to conserve Farmland
um again the the Greenland dairy farm
for example we're using l-chip funds
we're also using drinking water trust
fund funding from the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
each of those grant funding sources have
their own little set of restrictions
that you know the drinking water
restricts uh you know make sure that the
agriculture that's happening on site is
safe and will not disrupt the drinking
water
um so the the statute isn't really a
place to have uh specific
elements of the deed listed that's
something that comes together based on
every project thank you
and my question is typically
excuse me typically
um how is the funding used does the
person who owns the land the you know
the they get the fun the grant money to
do something with it how is that how
does that work yeah I can I can describe
that so uh the basic processes will do
an appraisal of the property that's
going to go into a conservation easement
uh what let's just say that appraisal
determines the conservation easement's
value is a million dollars
the land trust negotiates with the
landowner to determine a set value it
might be a million or the landowner
might be generous and say I'll take five
hundred thousand so that 500 000 would
go to the landowner and again Lynn
trusts are pulling that 500 money from
several different funding sources
including the federal government uh the
the program that we're talking about the
federal government brings 50 of that
value to the table
so it may be a situation where let's
take that same situation the easement's
worth a million dollars the federal
government provides 500 000 and the
landowner says they'll take 600 000.
that means we only need to find one
hundred thousand dollars somewhere else
to make that project fly so it's it's
not even it can be up to a one-to-one
match but it can actually be much more
favorable that the state could provide
uh five percent of of that uh payment so
every property is different has a
different value and it just depends on
how it's negotiated in in terms of
what the uses of the funds are that is
money that is strictly goes to the land
holder and they can do whatever they
want in many cases I've seen that it's
used to pay down debt to to allow the
farm to become viable but there's the
option of people have somebody who's
going to be the successor to that farm
this money gives the current
operators their retirement fund their
ability to be able to to pass that on to
the next generation and not have to rely
on an income stream from the operation
so it's whatever they want to do with
the funds that's not something I've ever
seen that there's restrictions on that
there are others that may purchase more
more property with uh with the funds and
and it's a one-time thing
um you know these landowners these
Farmers they only have one chance to
cash in that Equity that development
potential of the property so once that
transaction has passed
um the land is protected forever
um you know and we've done our job
representative Bixby yeah so
um a couple of things one is just just
to be clear what the
um what the landowner is selling is the
right to uh do any sort of development
that is not consistent with agriculture
or for instance building houses or
building you know factories or whatever
and they so that is a value that is part
of their land ownership that they have
chosen to sell and by selling that and
putting a deed restriction on it they
that deed says this gland can't be used
for anything other than agriculture so
is that a fair description that's a
really simple way of describing it okay
um and um
so I have a couple of questions about
um how this works in the language that
you've
um the the additional language you
suggested in 3224
um so uh when you have the phrase you've
inserted in several places the state's
interest in and
um how does that
uh oh well first of all if you see the
word extinguishment clause a number of
times and the term extinguishment Clause
never actually appears in the in in the
in in the language although that's
probably a lawyer's description of what
this Clause is yes
so
could you explain what that is and then
how the language changes here make that
um not a problem yes yes yeah so
um the commissioner used the term
extinguishment
um in the statute it's called release
and that's what section 24 is all about
so essentially
um under the under the old program the
rules written in the 1980s uh farmer
landowner could go to the committee and
say this land is no longer useful for
agricultural purposes and if the
committee agreed they would release the
conservation easement on the land and
the farmer would be able to do as they
please with that land again and and
that's what the commissioner was
referencing with respect to one of those
examples he provided
um that that may be the way they did
land conservation in the 80s but
nowadays
we think of perpetuity these
conservation easements as forever and
the only
examples of when you'd be able to
release or extinguish a conservation
easement is in an extreme circumstance
uh eminent domain which essentially
trumps every other property right uh we
understand that that may be a case or uh
commissioner referenced a huge chemical
spill or some kind of hazardous waste
and if if
everyone all of the interest holders of
that conservation easement agree you
will never be able to grow any food on
that property again then uh through a
Judicial proceeding that conservation
easement could be extinguished
so it's only under very extreme
circumstances that a Perpetual
conservation easement would ever be
extinguished so what we're doing here
with this release language is rather
than that leaving that decision up to a
committee is something that all of the
interest holders of the conservation
evening would have to agree to
and so the reference to the state's
interest back in the 1980s the state was
the only one holding these conservation
easements so this release language
described the process
now if we're going to be using federal
or other funding sources for this there
will be other interest folders involved
so this release language is is being
tweaked so that it just describes the
state's procedure for releasing but
won't enforce the way the other interest
holders would be able to extinguish the
easement and that's a requirement by
USDA they would never enter into a
conservation easement that only the
state could extinguish and and I think
if I may that first Red Line
um in 432-24 and as may be further set
forth in the terms of the deed that's
where those release terms would be set
out for for the others that that
language is uh were really I think sets
the table for that and then it just
changes it so we have an interest and I
will say that
um to the very best of my knowledge
there has never been a release of
development rights by this by the state
of New Hampshire that has not happened
that I have found anywhere
and I would just add to bring it even
closer to home that dairy farm example
where we're using drinking water trust
fund dollars
if we were to match those dollars with
Alp right now
the state looking at the interest that
the Department of Environmental Services
holds wouldn't allow this release
language
so even when we're using New Hampshire
state-based funding we wouldn't be able
to match it using this existing language
representative Bixby so uh so if there's
USDA funding for
um it's a USDA match than the USDA is
one of those interest holders correct as
and then if there's also say farmland
trust money they'd be another one and so
you could conceivably have you know
three or four different interest holders
on a given uh on deed restriction that's
correct and and the way this is now
written is each of those interest
holders would be able to declare and
describe how they would handle and
extinguishment
that's what this additional language
allows for thank you
and that's something that the landowner
would be aware of absolutely when they
when they uh agree to
um to this deed correct yeah so when
land trusts make an agreement with a
landowner it looks like a purchasing
sale agreement much like you would you
know when you're purchasing a home and
in that we stipulate exactly what the
deed language will look like for the the
Farmland conservation deed
would this make it easier or more
difficult for the landowner
at such a time where they decide they
want to sell their property
um that's a really good question I mean
obviously it would be easier for a
landowner to sell at least in my neck of
the woods on the Seacoast to sell a
Hundred Acre Farm to a developer this
would prohibit that so I guess in that
sense it may make it harder to sell that
property but again you know we're using
Public Funding to ensure that we have
some Farmland protected for the future
so I would argue that it's in the
benefit of the public to have some of
that land protected and while it may
make it a little bit more restrictive
for the landowner selling that property
I think that's the goal of this program
and if I may I don't I don't think that
anybody who's selling their development
rights the owners at the time are
thinking oh well in the future I'm going
to be able to get this back that's
that's not part of their thought process
now the next people who buy it may want
to try to figure out how to get it back
they're not the ones who benefited from
from the sale
thank you there's just no you have a
comment back there I'm sorry what's your
name
Nicole
it's easier or harder to sell the
participation under conservation even
changes your options as a landowner but
it is changes are neutral as I
understand it in terms of how it impacts
a way of doing the options
thank you and I would also add
conservation easements are entirely
voluntary there is no one out there
that's being forced to do a conservation
easement it's entirely their own choice
representative Contour
thank you madam chair
um I was just noticing that we're
changing the number of uh voting members
to eight normally on a board
um it's usually an odd number just
because
um so I was just wondering about that we
were talking about that on the walk over
and I think we'd be entirely open to
adjusting that I think our intent is to
make sure that there's someone from the
land trust Community or the land trust
Coalition that can help advise that
board so however you decide to
fit that interest in
if I if I may
um you know and I know that's done
because I was to avoid a tie vote
I think the likelihood of that happening
is is so remote is you know I would
rather not drop somebody off else often
and to just add somebody arbitrarily to
get to
uh you know a uh an odd number I don't
think has any any value
you could also add two members from the
land trust coalition
there any other questions that the
committee subcommittee might have about
this
uh representative Bixby yes uh you you
um mentioned the fact that there might
need to be rulemaking to bring the uh
this back up into the
um current decade uh and uh is that some
and so would having the land trust board
on a member on the board uh would that
would is the board involved in rule
making or well I guess would they be
involved because I guess this is a
prospective thing so this hasn't
happened for decades
I I am involving everyone that I can in
in getting the comments on this and of
course there uh is a public comment I
don't think the advisory committee
um
or has has a formal role in that but
certainly they will they will see it and
um I'm hoping to to start with that rule
making process very soon I'll be quite
Frank with you
um rulemaking is the most difficult
thing
um that I have come across and trying to
to uh to deal with the rules is is not
something that I'm comfortable with we
are in the process
of um hiring a part-time person who will
be doing our rulemaking and our
administrative judicial process
um that's about to close out and so I
should have somebody on board very
shortly and then we're going to be
starting with the rule making process
great so and you so you already have the
funding for that position we do great
thank you
uh is anybody else on the subcommittee
have any comments or questions about
this uh proposal
this legislation
um I just like to say that I think that
what we have here for language looks
like it's what's going to work and I'd
be happy to draft an amendment to bring
to the executive section and whatever
two or three weeks whenever we get to it
okay
this is not an early bill so we have
time to put a little work into doing
that and I'm amenable to that
no
okay
um I think we've kind of exhausted all
of our uh our questions and
on this particular Bill I'm glad we uh
we did get together because uh
apparently
this this didn't need a little bit more
work and consideration for other parties
uh and other language so this was good
any other comments questions from the
subcommittee if none I'm going to close
out this subcommittee work session and
we'll take a little bit break and then
come back at 10 o'clock
for
um our full committee work session on
the
HB 326 rodenticide bill so
let's take a little a little break see
you in a bit
foreign
okay I would ask that our committee
members take their seats please
foreign
okay uh I am going to open up the full
committee work session for
excuse me HB 326 prohibiting the use of
second generation anticoagulant
rodenticides
and I invite um
commissioner Jasper to say a few words
to our committee regarding some new
information on this
issue yes thank you madam chairman
members of the committee um I'm still
here in hopes that you will find the
bill in Expedia to legislate and I hope
to be giving you the reasons why why you
should do that we heard the testimony at
the hearing loud and clear heard what
was being asked for and as luck would
have it the pesticides board was meeting
yesterday
um and this was on our agenda and so
I'll just read you the memo here and I
apologize for running out of time and
not getting it to you all in advance at
its February 20 February 6 2023 meeting
the New Hampshire pesticide control
board uh motion to establish a work
group to review the concerns of Road
denticides residue in Wildlife the work
group is to include representatives of
the New Hampshire licensed pesticide
applicators New Hampshire division of
Public Health Services New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture markets and
food New Hampshire Fish and Game
department the University of New
Hampshire veterinary diagnostic
laboratory licensed New Hampshire
wildlife rehabilitators and New
Hampshire Audubon
so I think we have
done what everyone was hoping would
ultimately happen here we have a
preliminary
report date of August 1st recognizing
there may be something that would need
to be introduced for legislation
may not be enough time to to finish but
that's the target at the um
at the present time and certainly the
representatives representative of the
Audubon Society was present and we have
names from the other associations we'll
be reaching out to and establishes
director Russo has been tasked with
putting this
committee to together and getting to
work as soon as possible
representative Bixby yes I have a couple
of questions uh one is that we had
discussed uh in the committee uh early
some of us in the committee had
discussed the possibility of writing a
letter to the board asking them to do
this it sounds like they have already
done this so uh would such a letter be
redundant or should we say send a letter
saying thank you for doing this thank
you for doing this would be appropriate
because we have we have done it because
we did hear what what was going on and
we share the concerns about what's
what's happening uh and we want to
figure out how we can deal with this we
do think a lot of it needs to be solved
at the federal level by not allowing
homeowners to purchase this stuff in in
bulk or even in containers where they
can just throw handfuls of it all over
the place I think that's a large issue
and the FEDS are working on that but um
we will get into this more and figure
out what we can and representative and
my follow-up is uh you had suggested an
itl and I'm thinking but mentioned that
when the results come out was did you
say August 1st
that's hopeful some people think that
may be too aggressive
by by next fall yes um so if we were to
retain the bill in order to have a tool
if there is something that the board
feels they need legislatively do you
think that would be a better uh option
than it yelling it
I I I I suppose I mean you have the
option of putting a
a bill in in the fall anyhow so I right
I I guess that one of the issues that
sometimes comes up is that if the new
bill were deemed to be too close to the
old bill
the rules committee could say oh you
can't put that in yeah so there is
certainly no harm in retaining it thank
you Mr Speaker representative Creighton
thanks thank you commissioner thank you
madam chair
um that's good news expected
um that uh on the 21st of August the
report will come back from this work
group could you sort of highlight what
you expect from that report is it is
that a definitive you know this will be
I mean what kind of result would you
expect from that I would expect perhaps
recommendations as to
changes to our rules or changes to the
laws or perhaps and and perhaps
um recommendations that we make a
a send a letter to our Congressional
Delegation asking them to pursue changes
on a federal level if the feds have not
acted because these
um
these type of products
should be restricted in my opinion to
license applicators or in small
containers which are sealed that birds
and other type of non-target wildlife
can't get in into that's not currently
the case as
director Russo indicated
um I think here and then again yesterday
in some places on the internet a
homeowner could buy a five gallon pail
of this stuff
and just spread it everywhere which is
you know god-awful so but we can't
control that because
we only can control what is physically
sold in the state of New Hampshire and
people who are buying things on the
internet there's nothing we can do about
that uh and that is that I think is
likely to end up being
um
the final solution to this problem
although I am suggesting we can probably
do more to restrict in-state sales as
well
yes follow-up and and so okay excellent
the the one question I have is in your
opinion your estimation what's the
chance that that work group would kick
the can down the road for further study
I am pretty sure given some of the
people that we've put on here that
they're not going to have the desire to
do that I think the Audubon Society
representative in the in the uh animal
rehabilitate wildlife rehabilitators in
particular are going to want to get to a
solution on this quickly and I can tell
you I don't want to kick it down the
road I want to see us come up with some
solid recommendations
um by the end of certainly by the end of
August sooner if possible
um but I do know that
the feds have the biggest
role to play in in solving this this
concern thank you sir
thank you ma'am uh representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
question uh thank you commissioner just
to clarify for the record are you saying
there is zero oversight that you have on
anything coming online any online
purchases this is this is the problem
with anything that is sold on the
internet whether it be pet food or you
name it
we don't have the authority to you know
we can reach out at times
if we know who the companies are and try
to get them to not sell in the state if
it is a violation or anything but you
know our ability to actually enforce
anything on a company that may be based
in California in just selling online to
anybody is essentially nil
thank you representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question it seemed like in the
testimony we heard there was a gap in
the actual data collection as to what
was happening is there a thought as to
how that's going to be addressed well I
think that is the purpose of bringing
all these people together because it
became obvious that the Diagnostic lab
had told people something that we hadn't
been told in in the rehabilitators and
the Audubon Society had information that
we didn't have
so there is a problem in Communications
this working group will ensure that all
those parties come together and that
we're sharing all the same information
and then we can look at it in the same
manner that's something that hasn't
happened and frankly you know this
really
until last summer was something that I
had never heard of as a concern we
immediately went to work on it and that
one particular situation we dealt with
now it's obvious there are other other
concerns which we were not aware of
uh and um I have a question as to um
are we in touch with what kind of
studies the EPA is doing on these uh
substances
no but I'm sure that this working group
will will be interested in that and and
be uh
reaching out I mean again fish and game
maybe
I'm not so I don't know who knows what
bringing this group together will give
us the best information and I'm sure
that there will be Outreach to to
federal agencies do you know when they
have plans to meet next we got to get
the uh the uh
committee together I've tasked David
with David Russo of doing that as as
soon as possible so I'm hopeful by the
end of the month we will have a working
group together and have a meeting
scheduled thank you uh representative
datsey
thank you madam chair uh will these
committee meetings be open to the public
and will the public be able to comment
um that's a good question and generally
I would I would say yes we and I think
that's a good point we can advertise
um these meetings on our website and on
in the market both
I represent Bixby
so um
getting back to the ability to make
something restricted use
um
I a couple of questions on that one is
uh does the
um do we as a state have the ability to
restrict things more uh more strongly
than the federal government
I believe that we do okay and I I don't
want to give you a definitive on that I
wish David were here to answer that
question but my understanding is we do
and a follow-up sure so um I uh
I notice sometimes when I'm reading a
um uh agricultural products catalog uh
that uh they'll they'll be on underneath
some products not uh not allowed for
sale in such and such and such and such
so for instance if you're buying current
plants it says not allowed for shipment
to New Hampshire uh so uh it seems like
there is some capacity to say no you
can't sell that to us uh and I would
guess that you if you're talk if you
there might be companies like gemplers
which is pretty good about paying
attention to what state laws are that
will have that caveat and there might be
other ones that are sloppier but uh
there it seems like at least we could uh
reduce it if we had a further
restriction I agree the responsible
company will put that restriction in
place and I should also clarify that
once the product comes in if we find
somebody who is applying it against the
law we can take enforcement action
against the individual
so that doesn't exempt them from having
to comply with the laws once they get it
but but you're absolutely right there
are companies but unfortunately you know
in in the area of plant industry we get
an awful lot of plant dealers who are
shipping
plants into
the state that I restricted and they
should know that they should be aware of
that as should
the person who's selling it on retail in
the state but people don't all always
pay attention to those things
are only there to keep the honest
honesty
representative Howard
um I've I lost track a little bit of the
bill this is actually question made more
for the committee are we talking about a
restriction or a ban
the current bill
uh requests a ban on that particular
substance or a couple of different
substances so okay and
apparently this working group will get
together and discuss
the problem that we're having and how to
best solve it not so not necessarily
um this bill but the issue itself
so yeah sure um so uh we we would we
would entertain the idea of a
restriction or restricting it to Prof
pesticide or or debt decide
professionals would that would that be
an amendment that we could make
uh if we retain the bill we would have a
choice down the road of either
italing the bill or
passing it the way it is I imagine
representative Bixby yeah so
um the
there are several several different
methods of action that we can take as a
committee one is to pass legislation
another is to make to recommend to a an
existing body that they do a job which
they are currently empowered to do so in
this case the pesticide board is
currently empowered to investigate this
sort of thing and uh there I believe
that director Russo testified that they
do have the capacity to make uh certain
substances restricted use within the
state of New Hampshire so if the
pesticide board has the power to do that
completely then we wouldn't need to do
anything with the bill because they
could make it restricted use uh if they
uh if there's some piece of power that
they need in order further power from
the legislature that in the in order to
be able to do that then
one of our options would be to if we
retain the bill we could then amend it
to give them whatever power they need to
uh to to take further action uh so and
another thing that we can do is we can
just you know make a bill and say do
this and uh the department will be
required to do it but they might not do
it very well because we didn't we
weren't being cooperative with them and
you they have lots of things on their
agenda and you know that might not be
the top of their list so it always makes
sense to try to cooperate with the
Departments as much as possible because
they're the ones who are actually
executing what we write as loss
representative kantois thank you madam
chair
um so it is true that
um the director can put restrictive uses
on products even if they are legal
federally
um the governor is also very aware of
this uh bit uh
particular pesticide this rodenticide
and
has put it as one of his top priorities
in the state
I think that letting the pesticide
control board
and the working group do their job
is the way to go I would refer to itl
this and in the fall come back with
something based on the recommendations
of the working group if we need to do
anything legislatively
uh would be my thought
any other comments from the committee
um so yeah representative one one
advantage of doing it is retaining it as
opposed to
um as opposed to
having it as new legislation is that if
we retain it then it can we can get it
out a little bit faster in January
although uh rather than having a hearing
that we we would need to you know we we
need to have a public hearing then we
would need to have it voted on by the
four then we would have to have it go
over the Senate that process could be
moved up by a couple of months because
the bills that we have retained we have
votes on immediately in January and then
they go straight over to the Senate so
it could save a couple of months if we
uh have a retained bill that we can work
with and it doesn't really make a
difference in turn if if we decide in
the fall if the if the board says in the
fall we don't need anything we can just
itl it in the fall
foreign
any other further questions comments
thoughts about this
um
all right
okay uh representative Dotsy
thank you madam chair the commissioner
can I just ask you one question I'm
sorry this has been kind of like roaming
around in my head
um
I guess I'm concerned about the fact
that the
board the pesticide control board is
moving forward on this now okay when
this
this look this bill has been filed and
apparently they didn't see it as a high
enough priority before this so my my
concern okay so that's we haven't met
since May
and this is our first meeting since May
so this has not been something
that we would have had the opportunity
to discuss because it became an issue
after May
follow up follow-up
and I've been following the schedule and
that's my and and that's my concern okay
because I've seen a lot of the meetings
that get canceled frankly I saw the
meeting in January that was canceled and
I was amazed to find out that it was
rescheduled in February because I
thought it was just going to go into
April
so so I I do have some concerns that if
we don't take action in this committee
um that it's just going to be it's
there's going to be another cancellation
and another cancellation and it's never
going to get done well so
first of all the pesticides control
board only meets when needed
and we were scheduled to to meet because
we have we're in the rule making process
on three sets of rules
um but this has become a obviously a hot
button issue so it was on there the
board doesn't need to meet
to deal with this because of the fact
that we formed the working group and
that working group
is going to get to work and can meet as
many times this is not something where
the whole pesticides board control board
will be called together this working
group
will move right along I am calling you
know I will call and preside over the
first meeting
but as I've as I've told the control
board I'm doing that to get it organized
and to elect a chairman because what I
actually know scientifically about this
stuff you couldn't fill a thimble with I
expect to learn a lot more in the
process but I'm not the right person to
be chairing this particular committee we
need people on here who really know what
they're they're doing I will continue to
monitor their process progress and make
sure that they are meeting on a regular
basis uh and getting at least back to uh
back to the control board in August we
are as you know
scheduled to meet again in April which I
suspect has
a lot to do with the rule making process
it's very hard to get a lot of these
committees together because
you know as you've seen we can have a
problem with the Quorum so we have to
have a purpose to get together because
if we just call a meeting because oh
well it's been four or five months let's
have a meeting we're not going to have a
quorum so
representative Knapp
I would just say that I think
representative Dusty's Point speaks to
why you would retain it in committee
because you know I believe there's a
process in place here and we should
allow that process to play out it gives
us some oversight into making sure that
it plays out right if we retain in
committee if we feel like next year
nothing's or in 11 months nothing's
really happened we can revisit this
um but it you know I think the
commissioner's process has responded to
many of our concerns and I feel like
they're they're in a good place
nope
okay representative question no okay
all right anybody else have any comments
questions
okay thank you sir uh commissioner for
coming in and uh
placing your comments and we look
forward to hearing further from the
pesticide control board
and we will be writing a letter to uh
interested parties yes
would it make sense for me to direct my
letter to director Russo who can then
pass it off to the uh board or should I
direct it to you or
okay
okay so I will direct the letter to you
and it will essentially say uh thank you
for convening this uh study this uh work
group and uh we hope that you will come
up with an exposition just a resolution
thank you
okay I'm gonna close this um
this committee work session
and we'll take some time for our
individual caucuses to discuss this as
we come back at 10 45 to exec this bill
okay so
um I did not touch base with the office
to make sure that 403 is available but
it probably is so with Mr Democrats
let's go up to 403 and if we don't find
if we need to figure out something else
we'll figure it out okay and I'm going
to ask uh our folks in the audience
please to leave the room so that we will
have some time for our caucus to discuss
this
just came in today oh look at that so
you got two all right
all right
look at that wow
okay welcome back to environment
agriculture I am going to open up the
exec session for hb2 326 FN prohibiting
the use of second generation
anticoagulant rodenticides
wow this is loud
yeah
sorry
wake myself up
um so with this HB 326 do I hear a
motion
representative Creighton you're
Americanized I remember I moved that we
retain HB 326
do I hear a second
representative Murray seconds that
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Creighton
God yes ma'am I would
so uh committee heard testimony from
um bull State and private Audubon uh
animal Rehabilitation and the issues
truly compelling especially when you
look at the impact of the uh
the chemicals on
Wildlife
Raptors and foxes and and other things
we also heard the impact of not
addressing the rodent issues especially
in in homes with testimony about rats
and baby cribs and those types of things
so clearly very compelling arguments on
both sides
um the the fact that
we are charged with protecting wildlife
and the fact that we're also charged
with protecting our own families against
the diseases and and other things from
rodents
um as a committee we also heard
testimony uh this morning from the
commissioner that pesticides commission
has designated a work group that work
group has been charged with uh coming up
with very specific recommendations uh
which could range from restriction to
Banning to letters to the EPA in federal
agencies
um that that would address this issue
from my perspective uh the work group
should be given the opportunity to do
their job as they've been tasked to do
they've been directed to include the
Audubon Society they've been and as well
as
Rehabilitation folks uh in that in that
working group which was requested at the
testimony that we heard and so I
recommend that we retain this in order
to make sure that the commission and the
working group knows that we think it's a
very important issue that should be
resolved as quickly as possible and that
we do not want this to be pushed down
the road but that we do want some
definitive recommendations based on
evidence and study as they suggested by
the end of August so for those reason
ma'am I recommend we retain this Bill
thank you
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair uh yes I concur with
representative Creighton I would also
like to say that the working group will
have the opportunity to do all of that
in-depth work that we as a subcommittee
heard uh in or excuse me as a full
committee heard in testimony and again
heard uh here in the subcommittee work
group I also think it's important to
note that we will be issuing a letter to
the commissioner that will sort of State
our position as far as we're happy to
see that this is finally convening and
additionally we believe that should the
working group then have any
recommendations out of it they will then
report back to us and I believe it's um
just for clarification August 1st
hopefully not the end of August is that
correct uh yeah August 1st okay yeah
thank you and so then and hopefully in
August then we'll have some clear
Direction and if we need to use this as
a tool to do so we have it thank you any
other comments or questions
representative Bixby yeah I'd just like
to um mention uh sort of emphasize that
if the working group if that working
group uh realizes that they need
something that's a legislative solution
the having it available as a retained
bill will be the most efficient tool to
uh help them out with that
thank you and uh just from my own
personal comment I believe that the bill
written as it is
is not
um
is not a preferable
way to go uh I think the bill currently
written is is not a good bill I wouldn't
vote to pass that but I agree with you
that if we retain this and
there is some sort of legislative need
from the working group that will be
working on it that we will have a
vehicle in which to insert language to
do what they need
any other comments or questions about
this
okay seeing none I would direct the
clerk representative to call the roll on
the motion of retaining HB 326 okay so
the motion HB 326fn to retain
representative Creighton Creighton votes
yay representative yes representative
Rollins yes representative Davis yes
represent brilliard yes represent coulon
yes represent Kenny represent Potenza
yes represent smart
represent Bixby yes representative yes
representative Dotsy yes representative
Murray yeah representative Mana yes
represent Haskins yes representative
Howard
represent NAB represent Morse
representative yes Madam chair Madam
chair votes yes 20-0 motion passes thank
you
I appreciate the work of this committee
on this bill and I will now close the
executive session on HB 326.
now we only have until noon right yes
um we have until noon for our lunch
we're taking an early lunch today and
then we will resume with uh hearing
a couple of bills
thank you
foreign
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the environment and agriculture
committee we're going to begin our
hearing this afternoon with the Pledge
of Allegiance since I neglected the
earlier today to do this so
would you please lead us uh
representative Creighton
thank you
laughs
and I will open up the hearing this
afternoon
um with hb231 FN prohibiting the removal
of Claws from cats
and I call to introduce this bill uh
representative Mike bordes
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee I'm here to introduce
House Bill 231 this bill will make
non-therapeutic decoring of cats illegal
in the state of New Hampshire it does
have exceptions for therapeutic reasons
a lot of States counties
cities
numerous countries have already began
Banning the cruel declaring of cats for
too long the chlorine has been treated
as a routine Veterinary procedure
even though it is an elective and
non-therapeutic surgery meaning it has
no medical benefit to the cat it is
largely performed to prevent scratching
on furniture now I gave somebody an
example earlier today if your child
writes on the wall in crayon you don't
go and amputate the child's finger there
are other ways we can prevent cats from
scratching Furniture also
um I know I have two cats myself I have
two large dogs
um
if my cat is scratching the furniture
guess what I buy cheaper Furniture I buy
a couch cover I make accommodations for
the cat you get a scratching post with
catnip
um the chlorine is actually amputation
it is the amputation of the last bone of
each toe on that animal now that's the
equivalent to cutting off your finger up
to the first knuckle so again we don't
do that to our children for drawing with
crayons on the wall I hope
um because that would be considered
cruelty to that child
so why is it okay to do it to an animal
uh the standard method of the chlorine
is amputated with a scalpel or a
guillotine sometimes lasers are used but
not often the wounds are closed with
stitches or surgical glue and the feet
are bandaged up
um the procedure is essentially 10
complex amputations on the animal so the
cat has 10 front claws 10 front fingers
and they all get removed and amputated
uh
a cat's core is a complex digit it is
not just a fingernail like on a human
the nails retract and are actuated by
muscles and tendons by cutting into
these you raise the risk of serious
long-term physical and emotional impacts
on your cat the chlored cats in effect
are reduced to their ability to gain
traction and to walk properly so the cat
might gimple down a little more also a
lot of people
say oh it's just a house cat we could
Decor it it's you know it's scratching
my furniture what happens if that cat
gets into the wild it has no way to
protect itself
from predators or anything else so if
you have a house cat that somehow gets
out the front door the child leaves the
door open the calf wand is off it has no
way to protect itself you can't climb a
tree it can't claw at the Predator it's
really gotten no defense mechanism uh
the consequences of the chlorine are
larger than many people realize cats
behaviors can change some people this
cat will stop biting more after being
declawed as a defense mechanism
um some people will Decor their cats
cause say it scratches the person
I I still don't feel any animal
should be put through this crew
amputation just for the benefit of
furniture or maybe the cat scratch it's
natural it's a natural instinct so if
they go up to the you get get them a
scratching post with catnip if you don't
want a cat because it has claws you
probably should have never got a cat to
begin with in my opinion
um I make adaptations to my cats my dogs
I buy cheap furniture I got a 140 pound
dog likes to lay out on the furniture
you adapt to the animal
you don't amputate their digits
um
physical ailments such as premature
arthritis
uh perennial skin disorders occurred
Bungalow surgeries can result in growth
of deformed clause or serious infection
as well so I take it most veterinarians
are very good at what they do but if
something does go wrong with the surgery
it could lead to further complications
down the road like any other operation
um
also removal of the last digits of the
toe is drastically author's confirmation
of their feet and causes their feet to
meet the ground at a unnatural angle so
the cat might walk a little awkward not
not not in the manner the cat was
born to be walking and maneuvering the
American Association of feline
practitioners the Humane Society
Veterinary Medical Association
International Society of feline medicine
and the world's small animal veterinary
Association all the uh opposed declaring
animals
the Center for Disease Control and
prevention also does not recommend
declawing a cat several major Hospital
groups my vet is actually a member of
them including Banfield BluePearl VCA
have banned decoring all together so the
vet will not even the Chlor a cat if you
ask them to unless it was for a
therapeutic reason
again many counties countries cities
throughout the country
um have begun Banning it it's been
banned in New York for years upon years
Maryland has also banned it and I'm open
for any questions you guys have I just
really feel
that is cruel
to to do to an animal I wouldn't do it
to my dog would you declaw your dog
um dogs have what's called a dew core
some people do elect to remove them
personally I don't
um
again you wouldn't you wouldn't amputate
your child's hand for misbehaving so why
would you do that to your animal
thank you
uh representative you have a question
yes thank you madam chair and thank you
representative boards I'm just wondering
how many declarings actually happen in
the state of New Hampshire
they don't have an exact number I can
actually probably get that number for
you
it's enough that this is an issue in the
seed itself
follow-up thank you madam chair I have
um spoken with several veterinarians
um and over the course of
several years about the declaring of
cats
and as a rule and
they discourage declaring our cats
so does my understanding and and in
talking with some vet techs that if they
see one declaw in a veterinarian
hospital per year
that is Major in New Hampshire and
sometimes there are health reasons for
people
to be able to declaw their cats I'm not
saying that declaring is pleasant but
sometimes it's a choice of that elderly
person being able to keep their pets or
not and so I'm asking
um you know because we have heard this
bill several years want has the problem
increased or decreased in the declaring
of cats in the state
I don't have the exact numbers with me
right now I can get those over to you
um it is an issue I've spoken to very
quite a few vet techs and veterinarians
um a lot of them actually will not even
perform it
and this bill does have an exception for
therapeutic reasons
um I don't know of any medical condition
off the top of my head I could be wrong
with the corner of a cat would be
necessary
um that's just the way I look at it I I
just feel it's cruel
uh representative germana
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question so as as you said uh
most vets probably choose not to do this
for for reasons that you've you've
described well what would prevent a vet
who doesn't have those same Scruples
from Simply kind of recording in the
records that they did it for therapeutic
reasons right how does this law in the
end really stop uh the practice if in
the end a veterinarian can simply say I
did it for therapeutic reasons I think
they would have to show proof that it
was done for therapeutic reasons AKA and
X-ray and ultrasound or some sort of
mechanism to say hey this cat had let's
just say some sort of bone cancer and we
had to take care of the clue of the
animal I would assume um there is the
exception in the bill for therapeutic
reasons
I mean most vets I would
assume would be honest about it um I did
reduce this down to a civil fine
um I just have to speak into a lot of
veterinarians and people I just felt a
civil fine would be a better way to
handle this situation instead of going
after them in a criminal aspect
um the key is to deter this from
happening and and to kind of have a lore
on the books just saying hey we care
about our animals here in New Hampshire
and we don't want to do any inhumane
treatment
thank you for taking my question thank
you madam chair representative Potenza
uh thank you for taking my question so
you just stated that um the majority of
veterinarians and vet techs that you've
spoken to do not do this practice isn't
this bill um an overreach in regards
with private businesses as well as if
they're not doing it
um the majority of them are
what is the purpose of this bill
I do not feel this is an overreach
um I think it is our responsibility to
look out for our beloved animals again
if you chop a child's finger off it's
considered child abuse so why can we say
it's okay to chop a animal's claws off
just for scratching furniture
I don't understand how this could be a
government overreach it's it's a common
sense
aspect that we care about our animals
follow it
but I think the point is that we're
talking about Veterinary associations as
well that are only using this if there's
like something physically wrong with the
cat
um therapeutic that was mentioned I
didn't even realize that so
if we're talking 99.9 of everyone that
is in the profession agrees with you
what is the point of having this
I just feel it's something we want to
make sure does not happen just for
the benefit of furniture or
circumstances like that
um yeah there are a lot of veterinarians
that don't perform it but they're also
still some that you could go find that
will perform the operation again
therapeutic reasons health of the animal
perfectly fine but just to do it in a
cruel manage because you don't like the
cat scratching your furniture I just
don't feel is right
representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
question thank you representative
curious uh to know whether or not when
it says any person who violates this
section is that the person being the
owner of the animal or is that the
veterinarian
the way I understand and the way it was
I meant to write it would be the
veterinarian not the actual
um person
thank you for clarifying
any other questions
seeing none I want to thank you for your
uh introducing the bill today and I call
upon Nancy Holmes
to come and speak on this bill and I see
you have three minutes and written
testimony
appeared
here
did everybody get a copy of the
testimony on this side no we're going to
pass it around
thank you
go ahead
and Welcome to our committee
please put on your uh red just press the
button press There You Go technology
it's wonderful stuff my name is Nancy
Holmes I'm here today from New Boston
New Hampshire to speak in opposition to
this bill
um
I too was unclear as to whether or not
the bill was intended for veterinarians
only or for people who owned cats who
happen to have been declawed I know that
shelters Place declawed cats I know
people move here with declawed cats so
it would be an issue if it was going to
be somebody who owned the declaw cat was
going to be suddenly be fine for doing
so
um I think that choices in Veterinary
Care should remain between the animal
owner and their veterinarian
right now a veterinarian owner can in
Partnership choose to determine for
procedures right or necessary for pets
well-being
well-being can include the fact that if
the owner cannot declaw the cat they can
no longer keep the cat
some people resolve their problem with
the cat by Throwing It Outdoors
and claws are not the Predators around
here think cat's a nice tasty treat and
I know that in my neighborhood I am the
only person who has a cat that lives
into their teens and I had one go into
his 20s because my cats are indoor cats
the people who have at their cats
Outdoors replace them every couple of
years it's it's sad but you know it's
the way it is
um there are situations where for a cat
to remain in its home declaring is the
best option this may be to protect the
owner's health
some of you may know someone who's on
blood thinners and who have scratched by
their cat even innocently as it ran by
or whatever would be in severe trouble
from bleeding that's not an uncommon
situation for an elderly person to have
a beloved cat that's a little careless
with its claws
um
cats that don't conform to people's
expected behaviors
can be subject to a variety of
punishments for this
you could actually prevent cruelty to
the cat by having it declawed which
changes the owner animal relationship so
that the owner is happy with the animal
um
when you wonder what on Earth I could be
talking about for punishment think of a
cat duct taped
that's a that's one way to keep the
claws under control you just duct tape
all the feet not a good thing
um
you know there are cats that are really
easy to train to have their claws
trimmed to use Soft Paws to use only a
scratching post and then this cat's like
the one I have that's 12 years old that
my veterinarian refers to as the cat
from hell
um
not kidding it takes two vet techs and
the veterinarian to hold this cat to do
anything to it she and I have come to an
agreement she's an indoor cat only and
she's discovered that if she'll let if I
trim her claws she gets a really nice
treat there was a lot of wounds involved
before the cat got the point you know I
I just um
I'm willing to put up with that and deal
with that I'm willing to buy the cheap
furniture if a cat happens to scratch
the furniture not everybody is
um and that's that's true and that
doesn't mean they don't like cats it
means they may have a cat that just
suddenly they have a cat that does not
conform the expected Behavior
um
so it was mentioned that a cat a cathis
declawed that goes outside has no
protections against being attacked by
Wildlife or whatever
the truth of the matter is a cat that
doesn't have those protections is more
is less apt to fight and more apt to run
like crazy to get away from whatever the
hazard is
um
you know that you did mention those
medically necessary reasons for doing
such a procedure and
I just look at this bill and I think I
don't want the legislature telling me
what I can discuss with my vet as an
option to do I think most of the
veterinarians even the ones who do
declaws will sit there and talk and
counsel a person and discuss with them
all the other options they have
available to them before they go as far
as declaring I think if declaring is
done correctly it's no worse than any
other optional surgery we choose for our
animals and you know if you
if you try to think about well the cat
wouldn't want to lose its claws I
guarantee you the cat wouldn't want to
lose its ovaries or his testicles either
there's no no animal out there that
would agree to not being able to
reproduce
the um and the thing is you know any
surgery you do is hazardous to the
animal and yet we choose to do it anyway
because these are our companion animals
and we want them to be the best
companions we can have now in my case
I'll put up with the cat that that uses
its claws inappropriately and other
people's cases that's not possible and
again I know that there are many people
for whom it's medically necessary that
they have a cat that does not claw them
um
and what happens if they can't get the
cat declawed
what happens to that cat
end up in a shelter well there's like a
last time I checked it was like a three
or four month waiting list to get a cat
into a shelter if it was an aggressive
cat or a bad you know a difficult cat
that's not likely to get placed
um
there's a lot of things to consider here
I really do not believe that the
veterinarians in New Hampshire are out
there declaring cats every day I think
most people have cats with claws and if
the number of cat trees sold there's any
indication
um you know a lot of people try to do
different techniques to keep their cats
from chlorine anything they care about
but anyway I just want to say I'm
definitely opposed to this bill because
getting between a veterinarian and an
owner in terms of the patient's
well-being I just think that is
absolutely wrong
thank you very question thank you any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much and I
call now Joan O'Brien
and you requested two to three minutes
to speak
welcome
if anybody else has pink cards please
hand them up if they are interested in
speaking
foreign
thank you
um chairman Aaron members of the
committee
my name is Joan O'Brien I'm from Amherst
and I'm here today to represent the New
Hampshire animal rights league in
support of House Bill 231
I will let our hsus state director
address some of the
myths surrounding cat decline when he
testifies and I know that once again you
know many of you are here hearing this
for the second or even third time for
some of you it's new
and the fact that this legislation
continues to be proposed I believe
speaks to how adamantly the people of
New Hampshire want to see this procedure
retired through the law
during past hearings for the declaw Bill
much of the discussion is focused on
trying to establish how many cats in New
Hampshire are subjected to the procedure
and that's come up already this morning
I mean this afternoon
and I think while it's understandable
that we'd want to try and quantify the
problem for the individual cat whose
body is permanently altered the
percentages are irrelevant
um we have also heard in the past and
we'll probably again today
from veterinarians who say they have not
performed the surgery in a very long
time
and that they actively discourage it
and it would follow then that if the law
were changed to formally retire the
procedure would have little impact on
the veterinary business in New Hampshire
as far as concerns about making
criminals out of veterinarians any
veterinarian who acts in the best
interest of the cat would have nothing
to fear
lost my place
if needed the medical exemption is
always available
New Hampshire citizens are more
concerned about the real and present
danger to cats then to the outside
possibility that a veterinarian might be
asked to justify a declaw surgery
once in a blue moon
as long as this procedure is legal in
New Hampshire some people will still
have it done
if passing this law could prevent even
10 cats that one percent
from during this crippling surgery why
wouldn't we
so we urge the committee to support this
bill so the New Hampshire can retire
this harmful and unnecessary practice
okay I
are you willing to ask all the questions
okay questions
representative germanna thank you madam
chair thank you for taking uh my
question so I was I'm wondering is
similar to the question I asked the the
representative are you familiar with
when other states have banned this
practice what requirements do they have
on a veterinarian to document medical
need right because as I said unless
there is some specific
requirement regarding the keeping of
Records should there be an inquiry I can
imagine again most veterinarians are
going to do this but if we think about
the veterinarians who will do it uh if
it's a matter of them simply stating uh
that they are doing it for for a
therapeutic reason a medically necessary
reason I I find it hard to see how the
law would be effective so in any way are
you familiar in places where it has been
outlawed what the requirement is on the
Bahar on the behalf of veterinarians to
document medical need
no I'm not but I believe that when
something becomes illegal that is going
to be enough of a deterrent for a
veterinarian to to not not even consider
performing the procedure and we have
many laws where we where it is just out
there to be used when needed if there's
a question or a suspicion
thank you very much thank you madam
chair
representative Knapp
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um I wonder if you
did speak to how complicated the surgery
is because just looking at your hand out
really quickly you have an article about
bone fragments and the complications
that can arise from the surgery so
is there concern that if you have fewer
people doing these surgeries they'll be
worse outcomes over time
are you are you asking if we'd have less
expert expertise if the procedure were
less common well yeah I guess it's sort
of a two-part question that and is it
considered a complicated surgery that
you do sometimes have these adverse
outcomes with relationship to the Bone
fragments that are mentioned in this
article we have heard from veterinarians
in at past hearings that it is actually
rather a a crude surgery
um you know just basically an amputation
and
with the outcome often being completely
unknown and and and a cat leaves and you
never know what problems it is taking
with it if done improperly bone
fragments can end up
um being you know retained Under the
Skin and the cat will feel as though
it's walking on the pebble for the rest
of its life and that's just sort of an
uncomfortable outcome there are there
are there are worse health risks such as
developing arthritis
um it throws off a cat's balance as the
bill sponsor mentioned and that can
really that can lead to other
um
complications with the cat's posture
any other questions
oh follow-up sort of a separate question
but I wonder
um how your organization Compares this
with other sort of elective surgeries
such as tail clipping or ear clipping in
dogs
you view it as similarly
undesirable painful
today we're just talking about cat
declawing
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today I call Kurt Ehrenberg to
testify
in support of the bill and you've asked
for three minutes
good afternoon I am Kurt Ehrenberg I'm
the state director of the Humane Society
of the United States and I'm here to
support
the bill
um
clearly this is a barbaric practice that
no
pet owner that loved their pet would
perform on their pet
I think we have to make sure we're
talking we know what we're talking about
if if I were a cat
it'd be lopping off my fingers at the at
the knuckle
so that's what this is it's not a declaw
where they pull out the claw it's taking
off the fingers the toes whatever you
want to call them
it's irreparable
it's cruel and barbaric
there is no we cannot find in this state
a reputable veterinarian who says they
do it
which is why you cannot quantify
uh the incidences and we cannot either
as a citizen of New Hampshire I think we
should not rely on the unknown
in order to decide not to stop a
barbaric practice that would affect the
animals in this state
and my job is to represent the animals
in this state and uh today for the cats
that face this because they may have an
owner that's
too lazy to figure out how to protect
their furniture
who believes erroneously that uh cat
claws are a
uh
a danger to their health I mean I would
just say that
I broke down somewhere
there's no there is no
diagnostic therapeutic
reason for this surgery
again find me a vet that says they
perform this for any reason at all
is there anyone here no so why are we
continuing to as a state to support this
practice
just because we can't quantify the
incidences
and I would just go over I mean I did
email to you all my testimony so I hope
you have that
um my practice is usually to read the
testimony so actually you hear it
but I think today I will not do that I
asked for three minutes
I mean what I want to say is this is a
barbaric practice there's no good reason
to continue it and let's just stop it
and I'm happy to take questions
representative Contour
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um you just stated that there was no let
me just go back there and read your
words there is no diagnostic therapeutic
reason to perform this surgery
is that correct
that is my understanding
follow-up uh thank you madam chair so
the section that says that a
veterinarian can perform it for a
therapeutic
reasons
do you believe that is necessary to be
in that bill
I believe that Veterinary uh profession
should have the ability to perform
procedures that they think are
absolutely necessary I'm not a
veterinarian
I do not have the expertise I can only
give you my opinion
professional and personal
representative Creighton
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony I just want to
I think that you just said there are no
reputable veterinarians that are
performing this in the state of New
Hampshire as far as I know
Okay so
for a follow-up follow-up so that means
no one's doing it
we can't find anyone who'll admit to
doing it we do know
that that the that this happens all over
the country in places where it is banned
it happens much much less frequently and
just to to to to answer the question of
if if a if a veterinarian can lie to us
and say that it's therapeutic
um then why would we pass this
legislation I mean you could say that
about any any criminal uh violation or
penalty law against any crime okay thank
you
representative Bixby
yes so if it's so hard to find people
who are doing this uh what would the
mechanism for enforcement be
it's in the bill
that's the that's the penalty but how do
we find the people who are doing it so
well the so I would think that any
veterinarian who was a professional who
did all the schooling and all of the
work to become a veterinarian care for
these animals
would not be lying to us about a
barbaric procedure that they some for
some reason wanted to undertake
thank you representative Contour thank
you madam chair and thank you again for
taking my question
now
sometimes
there's kind of like a
owner
veterinarian relationship going on here
and if the veterinarian has done
everything that they can in discussing
and the only option for that person that
owner to keep that cat is to declare it
don't you think that should be between
the owner and the veterinarian
well I think that's the issue we're
talking about
any other questions
representative
thank you madam chair uh yes how many
cats do you currently represent and how
many of them are in danger of getting
their claws removed
thank you
I
don't directly represent any cats I
don't own a cat but I uh represent all
the animals in the state through my
organization the Humane Society the
United States
any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
and I now call Angela Ferrari
and you've requested three minutes as
well and I see you have testimony thank
you
one for everybody
welcome
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Angela Ferrari and
I'm here on behalf of dog owners of the
Granite State we are a membership of
responsible local pet owners and we do
include cat owners and cat breeders as
well
um I am here to oppose this bill and
more so on the fact of how it gets in
between the veterinarian and the owner
not so much as a particular supporter of
the procedure itself but just the fact
that if we start telling veterinarians
what they can and cannot do I think
we're stepping over a boundary and as
the testimony that you have previously
heard most veterinarians if not all in
New Hampshire are not performing this
procedure unless it is absolutely
necessary
um
we don't think that it's an issue of
Humane treatment of animals and actually
legitimizes activist campaigns to
unnecessarily restrict the rights of
animal owners and veterinarians
the avma respects the veterinarian's
right to use professional judgment when
deciding how to best protect their
individual patients Health and Welfare
and we agree with them and always
recommend working with an animal to curb
bad behaviors before turning to a
medical procedure however when all else
fails and a veterinarian determines and
this is the veterinarian determining
that decline is the only remaining
solution that decision should remain a
choice between owner and veterinarian
um as you've heard most veterinarians
are not performing this procedure we did
have one of our members last year when
we heard this bill previously call and
talk to veterinarians and more than 50
percent of them couldn't remember the
last time that they had even performed
it and most of the facilities in New
Hampshire aren't offering the procedure
so we think that that's a clear
indication that this is not an issue
here in New Hampshire and I think you'll
hear more from the NH VMA
um
speaking of elective convenience
procedures which is what we're hearing
this most referred to when it isn't
being used for therapeutic purposes also
mentioned by Ms Holmes previously Spain
and neuterine is considered an elective
and convenience procedure and with any
procedure there's going to be potential
for side effects if in the documentation
that was handed out I'm sure you saw
some pretty gruesome images I'm assuming
if you were to see images of near any
procedure that's surgical it isn't going
to be very pretty that's why we have
veterinarians who are trained to do
these procedures and it isn't something
that just anybody does
but that is any procedure that happens
and there are side effects even when you
get your cat or dog spayed there's
potential that a piece of the ovary
could be remaining and they could
continue to have side effects from that
um just for a small example
in my testimony that I had emailed
yesterday to you I included an article
for a bill in Missouri which would
actually reverse a similar bill that was
passed there in 2019 this is their
sb-115 this bill would protect
veterinary medicine while HB 231 the
bill we're discussing today actually
opens the doors to restrict veterinary
medicine here in New Hampshire
we should not legislate anything that
prohibits restricts limits regulates
controls directs or interferes with the
practice of veterinary medicine and that
is actually the language that is used in
the Missouri bill
that bill has the support of many
organizations including veterinarians
the American Veterinary Medical
Association the Farm Bureau of Missouri
the Federation of animal owners among
many others and I did include a link to
those organizations who signed in in
support of that bill
um so lastly I think that we need to let
the veterinarians continue to educate
their clients about Decline and not make
anyone's criminals if they feel it's
best to perform this necessary procedure
I also find it a big ask to expect
veterinarians to have to start providing
proof and justification for procedures
that they are performing when they feel
that they are suitable for the animals
what procedures is that going to be next
are we going to have to have a registry
where they're submitting proof to move
forward with performing procedures I
think that actually could hinder
procedures happening to animals if this
is needed on the veterinarian's behalf
so I thank you for considering my
testimony and hope that you will vote
this bill in expedient to legislate once
again
to avoid implementing legislation that
prevents owners and veterinarians for
making the best choice for New Hampshire
pets and I would be happy to take any
questions thank you
representative germano thank you madam
chair and thank you for your testimony
for taking my question so I am as my
previous question is kind of indicates
kind of skeptical about whether or not
this will address really address the
problem that it's intended to but to
play Devil's Advocate at what point does
any procedure right
dealing with an animal become cruelty
right in the sense that the sponsor
referred to to the cruelty of this we
have laws which prevent cruelty to to
animals and the kind of the bar
historically as to what constitutes
cruelty has moved a lot over the years
so I'm curious as to your thoughts about
at what point uh a procedure for example
for an animal becomes cruel because this
bill does have an exception for for
medical reasons so in that sense a
veterinarian would would be within their
legal rights to perform a procedure if
it was for medical reasons so if if you
could share with us your thoughts about
why this doesn't in your mind cross that
threshold and become cruelty
I think that if this procedure was being
performed not under a licensed
veterinarian's care without anesthesia
for example then you would be venturing
into a cruelty consideration I think
that if a veterinarian who does have an
oath that they take when they become a
veterinarian that they're going to do
the best that they can for the animal
protection of Animal Health and Welfare
the prevention and relief of animal
suffering the conservation of animal
resources the promotion of Public Health
and the advancement of medical knowledge
if they aren't adhering to that oath
then we could enter into a cruelty
situation
thank you very much thank you madam
chair representative datsey
thank you madam chair we have many uh
laws on the books that ban practices
um between that that a doctor and a
patient might feel that is in a
patient's best interest so why is this
ban any different for animals
I think because there are many reasons
that it could need to be done it's
something that can be done with
anesthesia in proper procedural ways
that's been done for many years with
many positive outcomes and if the
veterinarians and the owners feel that
it is appropriate for the animal then it
should remain between them to make that
decision
follow up
uh yes but can you speak specifically to
the doctor-patient relationship and the
animal veterinary relationship because
basically we do have laws on the books
that ban doctors and their patients who
agree on a procedure from doing various
things and I see this bill as basically
doing the same thing so I don't
understand why one relationship is okay
but the other isn't
thank you I am not a doctor and I am not
familiar with those type of bands that
are in place so I couldn't speak to that
specifically I'm here on behalf of the
animals and the animal owners
any other questions
thank you thank you for your testimony
today and I call Representative Ellen
Reed
um
welcome
thank you thank you madam chair and
thank you honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
that's new market and new fields and
also for the record I own own care for
three cats all like their ages are 16 15
and 14 I've had them all since their
kitten hood and I've in my adult life
and well into my childhood I've never
been without without multiple cats so I
it's a topic I consider myself well
versed in
um
you have repeatedly heard I think the
main argument from opposition on this
bill and I am in in support as a
co-sponsor
is the concept of private decision the
private decision between a doctor and uh
the owner of an animal
um
there are many cases as was brought up
that we interfere with those private
decisions in fact that idea of private
decision has consistently been used over
the ages as an argument to prevent
restrictions on cruel behavior
um when we were putting in place uh
protective measures for children there
was the argument of parents well I
should be able to beat my children
that's a private decision as the the
parent of the child I recently saw a
documentary I think it was in Iran where
a man and this is a topic of much uh
discussion there today A man was
vehemently defending his right to beat
his wife
because it's his private home and his
private relationship with his wife and
nobody should interfere they should get
out of his business when uh measures
were proposed to uh mandate certain care
requirements for slaves
slave owners came back and said that's a
private decision the slaves are my
property how dare you
and I am personally responsible for
extending a anti-cruelty measure which
we heard that same exact language
private private decisions we do
interfere because with private decisions
because private decisions sometimes are
not acceptable sometimes there are Bad
actors in fact I would argue that all of
our law is written for Bad actors not
good actors Benjamin Franklin said that
if all men were Angels government would
not be necessary
so we do we do do that
um
the another argument I heard was the
health of the owner this is another one
I've heard over the years
um so just for the record there are
little claw caps that are very easy
cheap to buy and easy to put on there's
also claw trimming that's easily done to
prevent scratches if an owner I mean you
could argue that maybe if someone was
particularly concerned about scratches
that perhaps they shouldn't have a cat
anyway or maybe any animal but
a very simple easy alternative to make
sure you're not getting scratched
however if you declaw cat
you're looking at a much worse Health
consideration for the owner because cats
that are declawed resort to biting much
much sooner and when this came up last
time around I I because this issue was
was brought up I asked a medical doctor
for the record which is worse to treat
in humans a cat scratch or a cat bite
and universally cat bites are harder to
treat they are usually more penetrative
and more infectious
we heard a few moments ago someone say
and I wrote down the phrase because it
it bothered me that the surgery would be
necessary for the owner to be happy with
an animal and there's your line for
cruelty because it's right in the bill
that you can do it for medical reasons
but not cosmetic aesthetic or reasons of
convenience if you are mutilating an
animal for cosmetic or convenience that
is cruelty it's a pretty clear line for
me if you're doing a surgery for medical
reasons so the animal can live in happy
and healthy life long term that's not
cruelty but I do want to point out the
false uh equality that they they drew
between sterilization and this
particular thing when you undergo
sterilization when an animal does that
soft tissue you are not cutting through
bone you are not cutting through tendons
you are not cutting through ligaments
that is just soft tissue you're removing
an organ much like I've had my
gallbladder removed many of us have had
our wisdom teeth removed those in those
cases there are very rarely
complications long term and they are not
intended for the surgery right but when
the case of amputating the fingers the
ligaments the tendons and the bone in
these cases and then the other the other
thing I wanted to say is people aren't
forced to crawl around on their surgical
wounds but a cat is forced to walk on
those surgical wounds to use the litter
box with those surgical wounds so yeah
there's a big big difference between
sterilization also people voluntarily
undergo sterilization all the time so I
don't I don't think it's necessarily
true that any animal if we could ask
them would simply say no it's cruel to
sterilize me
continuing on I do want to point out
lines 10 through 12 someone said oh this
must has to be limited to only vets and
it says any person no it needs to be any
person if you do a quick Google Search
right now on your phone for at home
declaw kit they exist they are sold
people do them at home often without any
sort of anesthesia and certainly not
putting them under like a general
anesthesia like a doctor would do so
yeah it should be any person
foreign
oh yes
um the idea is that therapeutic I think
the bells the bill spells it out really
clearly but yes there are situations
when in which this is truly medically
therapeutic if the animal has cancer in
the bone if the animal otherwise needs
to amputate has an injury or some
deformity needs to amputate a finger
that this is specifically how this is
written so that doctors can do it for
medical medically legitimate reasons
again it's the line is when you mutilate
an animal for cosmetic aesthetic or
reasons of convenience
um like back to the idea of how many
vets do this do vets do this yeah 99.9
of the Vets don't do this the other 0.1
percent don't admit to it so then the
idea was how well how do we enforce it
if they're not admitting to it
um people tell
right nurses the front desk staff that
see this people tell and that's how a
lot of crimes are actually enforced as
people tell
uh but there are vets like again there
are Bad actors everywhere this is why we
have laws there are vets that do bad
things that's why this is necessary my
personal vet would never perform a a a
declaw I asked him and actually I asked
every single doctor in that office
but he told me a story of an owner a pet
owner I think it was a cat actually it
turned out the cat was allergic to her
perfume and the vet my vet told her this
you know you have to stop wearing the
perfume around the cat and she said that
she wanted to put down the cat rather
than stop wearing her perfume he refused
to do that but he knows that she went to
another vet who agreed to do it so there
are Bad actors and we legislate because
of Bad actors
uh the last thing I want to bring up
is the opposition that you've heard over
the years on this bill is
I'll say almost exclusively from the AKC
and dog groups they are afraid of the
slippery slope because if we do this for
cats then the next step will be ear
cropping and tail docking but this bill
is about cats and declawing and I plead
with this committee to consider this
bill and not any potential future bills
about dogs but only the health of cats
and declawing and with that I'm happy to
take questions
representative germana thank you madam
chair and thank you very much
representative uh and I understand
absolutely right that we legislate for
for Bad actors but in any case where we
legislate for Bad actors but we carve
out exceptions right we have to to
representative bixby's Point have an
enforcement mechanism right we need to
be able to decide who is a bad actor who
is doing this for you can murder but you
can kill himself defense but you also
need to demonstrate right so clearly in
case so again my question is also do you
have in mind as a co-sponsor a specific
way that that mechanism would work so
for example if it were a matter of on
the paperwork a veterinarian simply
saying yes you know I I determined that
this was medically necessary that
obviously is not a very effective
enforcement mechanism so are do you have
in mind other forms of for example
requirement of documentation in the case
of veterinarian so that if a case comes
up they can demonstrate the need thank
you for the question it's a good one so
like any other criminal case the
prosecution has to go and collect
evidence in a case such as this the idea
that a doctor is going to claim that
when perhaps a witness is reporting them
saying that they performed a cosmetic
only declaw and the veterinarian would
claim oh it was for medical reasons then
in that case a prosecutor could for
example go to the board and ask them for
a determination on whether that was
medically necessary or not according to
the medical records that would be one
sort of uh you can also call in court
Specialists Court experts into such a
court case and ask them to in their
medical opinion tell whether or not that
was medically necessary or done for
cosmetic reasons
thank you very much and thank you madam
chair
your questions representative Murray
I'm sure
you mentioned this is you're teaching me
something new about the at-home decline
what what rates of instance or do you
have any information or data for us on
that other than a quick Google search
like do you know to what I don't have
any and I don't know how one would go
about finding that information it's not
like there's an agency in New Hampshire
that registers everyone who bought a
at-home d-clock hit online like note the
state doesn't know what you buy online
of any type not just uh cat declaw kits
so I would have and we have no way of
knowing that but again like with all
crimes that are most crimes are done
intended to be done in private and then
someone somewhere knows something and
goes to law enforcement
so I have a follow-up question to that
if we banned decline in this state
wouldn't that push people to do things
illegally a purchase a a at home declaw
kit and then cause even more damage to
their to the animals well as we've
already said 99.9 percent of vets don't
do this so by and large if someone's
going to a vet asking for a cosmetic
declaw they're being told no which means
if they're very serious about it they
may already be buying those kits all
we're doing is making that behavior
illegal the behavior that and again
we're talking about a small number of
people a small number of people murder
but we still make laws for it because
it's wrong so what we're saying is now
we have an enforcement mechanism because
what you've been doing is cruel and now
we can go after you for it because at
the moment we cannot
further questions
seeing none thank you thank you madam
chair and I call Jane Barlow Roy
Welcome to our committee
you see the red light so there you go I
did it right
all right well um thank you committee
for letting me speak in front of you
today my name is Jane Varla Roy I am a
veterinarian here in the Concord area
um I have been practicing veterinary
medicine since 2006.
um
and I've been here in New Hampshire the
entire time I am currently representing
the New Hampshire Veterinary Medical
Association in front of you today I also
represent New Hampshire at the American
Veterinary Medical association's House
of delegates so I guess I'm representing
both the avma and the New Hampshire VMA
in front of you today
I'm kind of not really sure where to
begin
um because like many others that have
come before me we have testified several
times and so right now I have a lot of
things spitting
um in my head but I guess I'll just
start with
things that have already been kind of
said
um the avma does not support routine
decline they have a position statement
that is readily available if you go
online you can read that for yourself I
can get that for you if you would like
the that language but it does
specifically state that they do not
support legislating it so we do not
support it as an association but we do
not support legislating and making it
illegal as well and that is definitely
something across the board without other
Allied organizations they stop short as
as far as creating legislation regarding
decline
the New Hampshire VMA is also actively
discouraging the practice with our
veterinarians and we have
um sent out over the last few years
um a bunch of surveys to get what the
New Hampshire veterinarians are
participating in we only represent about
400 veterinarians in the state this is a
member LED we do are separate from the
the board certification of the board of
veterinary medicine which represents
more of us so we do not have everybody's
opinion and to kind of address those
questions of how often we're doing it
we've tried to get those answers but
again we only can do what we get back
from our from our membership but it
isn't overwhelmingly no we do not
perform this procedure to the extent of
of when we I even graduated in in 2006
it has something that has significantly
fallen off in the last 17 years that
I've been practicing
again I'll also comment I do not
remember in recent memory the last time
I did proceed perform a declaw procedure
it's at least seven to eight years could
be more but my my memory does not serve
me to those specifics
additionally
um many of the private practices around
here
um
also have the ability to as a practice
decide not to perform these declaw
procedures
it was also brought up that many of the
corporates that are practicing here in
the state have already banded at a at a
corporate level so this includes
Banfield VCA and and the like so I guess
I'm reiterating that point
um
I did have the opportunity as a last
avma meeting back in January
um I had a chance to sit down with
students at the veterinary schools and
I've talked to a Veterinary
clinicians that are at the teaching
level to kind of get a sense of what's
going on in in the Veterinary Schools
right now it is across the board pretty
much a non
um
something that's not being taught in
schools right now it is definitely
something that has lost favor at the
school level the schools that do offer
it are offering it more at a
um what we would call a lunch and learn
or something that they do on their own
private time not something that is part
of the the specific curriculum so I got
that information for you
I think the big the big issue
um when we're talking about the
privatization and it's a private matter
um
I think veterinarians our ultimate goal
is to preserve the human animal Bond
that is the Crux of everything that we
do you get a pet you love a pet and it
is our job as veterinarians to take care
of that pet and make sure that they are
happy and healthy and living their best
lives
um
like I said we do not promote the
decline we we work with our clients if
they do bring it up
um we sometimes have to get explicit
about explaining what the procedure is
and a lot of times that's enough to
deter somebody
um but like that's already brought up we
do offer nail trimmings we teach clients
how to trim their cat's nails we also
provide the the claws the claw caps and
and things like that as well so we are
trying our best to deter and like I said
I think we're as a Veterinary profession
we've done a pretty good job at
educating our clients um you know now
these days so that we aren't performing
this this procedure anymore
so I will take any questions that you
guys have for me yes I have a question
I'd like to know how often are people
successfully dissuaded from declawing
their cats when they request it from
their veterinarian
I can only speak for myself
um I would say I've got 100 success rate
because I have not performed the
procedure in at least like I said seven
to eight years our practice as a whole
is a three doctor practice here in the
Concord area I would consider ourselves
pretty busy
um
I think
most of us are having pretty positive
conversations
um like I said about deterring because
they can get on the internet and you
know Google declaw and they see the
explicit photos they see exactly what it
is
um I think the mindset
um has definitely changed in the last 17
years that I've been practicing about
what it is it used to be Spady claw
nudity claw you know that was on the
books you know and you just people just
did it because they felt like it was
something that they that they did
um that is definitely not the case
anymore
um people are definitely asking
questions
um they're definitely having those pause
moments
um and I can say even for the the
reasons of medically necessary
when I mention
amputating as a treatment option
they exhaust all the other options first
so even in those medically necessary
situations
um so it is definitely something that I
feel we've done a really good job of of
client education thank you
representative Dotsy
thank you madam chair if this bill
passes what harm does it do to
Veterinary Professionals in the state of
New Hampshire
foreign
I think the harm to veterinarians
is going to be
more of an emotional harm because we are
always going to think is somebody going
to tell on us
is a client going to tell on us is your
neighbor going to tell on you is that
disgruntled front desk staff is that
disgruntled technician is the practice
down the street that's comparing
competing with you going to tell on you
social media has not been friendly to
the veterinary profession over the last
few years and I feel that
we as a profession are constantly
in the thick of things and even if it's
not going to be
it's something that
by putting
a criminal penalty for something that we
may have to stop and think about what
we're doing and what kind of
consequences could be
um
I think that is the the biggest
thing that we're going to think about
the biggest harm and so I have a
question so
with respect to
this being considered a barbaric and
cruel procedure to do
how it how would it be cruel and
barbaric
for one instance versus not cruel and
barbaric for none another instance I
mean if you
if you remove it up to you know the
knuckle
whether it's for therapeutic reasons or
for not therapeutic reasons it's still
removing it up to the knuckle and you
still run the risk of maybe having a
bone fragment that's going to be a
pebble in their foot or some other issue
so could you clarify how
one instance may be considered a better
reason than another try I will try
I I think the the thought that we're
doing declaws under no anesthesia or
pain medication is is kind of a
falsehood any medical procedure that
we're doing at a veterinarian's office
is is going to be
um under the scrutiny of a standard of
care so there are a variety of different
kind of standard of cares that we have
to in our in our Veterinary Practice Act
adhere to or we will be brought up
against the board of veterinary medicine
and so the thought that
it's going to be barbaric and cruel to
declaw versus amputating a limb
um re versus removing an eye for a
different procedure there are different
ways that you can kind of make those
definitions
um and I think as long as we are
adhering to what is accepted as a
Veterinary Medical Practice as that
standard of care
we're not going to necessarily be
accused of Cruelty because there's a
variety of other things that if you're
not doing the standard of care
um
it can and you're not treating it
appropriately that could be considered
cruel barbaric
um and so I think part of it is is
possibly a semantic issue
um a definition issue
so
as long as you're adhering to those
those standard of care practices are
there any other procedures that are
banned
that you as a veterinarian cannot
perform in New Hampshire
not that I know of
thank you representative Bixby
so we heard testimony that uh there are
at home declaw kits have you seen
evidence of any animals coming into your
practice or heard from any other vets in
New Hampshire about uh seeing animals to
whom this has been done by the home uh
by someone at home
as far as I have seen no
um
I can't like I said I can't speak for
all the veterinary practices out there
no
follow it
um just from your reaction I can tell
that you don't think that's a good idea
no
um because one of the biggest things
that we had always heard about wanting
to declaw your cat was I can't trim the
cat's nails at home so in my opinion if
you can't trim your own cat's nails at
home
how on Earth are you going to declaw
your cat's nails
art claws at home either I'm having a
hard time wrapping my head around that
concept
uh just one point before I get to
representative esophageitis uh I I just
Googled that uh at home declaw cat kits
and they are gel caps you put on your
cat's claws so anyway uh representative
sophakitis
that's a tricky number to
kind of figure out the last we knew the
board of veterinary medicine had around
900 licensed veterinarians in the state
of New Hampshire that being said border
towns and border cities will have dual
mem certifications so you know
Massachusetts Vermont Maine will have
both a New Hampshire license and a
Vermont license
in our membership we have or last year's
2022 we had 400 roughly 400 members but
like I said we are we're we're very
difficult to get those actual numbers of
the veterinary practicing veterinarians
here in the state
foreign
germana thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question
um I'm going to kind of reframe the the
chairwoman's question a little bit and
make it slightly more pointed I think
um
obviously the bill allows for exceptions
and therapeutic purposes right for
medically necessary things that a vet
determines to be medically necessary
given the impact uh over the life of the
animal not simply the procedure but the
possibility of developing arthritis uh
you know questions around if the cat is
is uh less able to defend itself if it
should be outdoors Etc so uh given the
possible impact over the life of the
animal do would you say that declawing
for purely cosmetic or reasons or for
reasons of convenience is cruel if it's
if it's purely for cosmetic or reasons
of convenience in your opinion would
that be cruel to the animal
no
because there are reasons that have
already been stated about why somebody
would choose to declaw their cat and
if
the ultimate reason for choosing to
declaw your cat is based on preserving
yet human animal Bond
then to me that's not a cruel decision
because there's no intent to
harm
physically harm your cat in an
intentional way
um that's that that's not something that
and you're not doing it like I said
without anesthesia pain medication
um there are ways to mitigate
those
things
um and with any surgery there are
complications and so to use that as
um
a reason too is is is not
the same
thank you very much thank you madam
chair representative Knapp thank you for
testifying thank you for taking my
question can you just um clarify then
why the avma recommended against this
procedure if it's
not cruelty is it long-term side effects
is it I think it's there's there's from
what we
from what we know is is
the
Society has changed in their opinions on
things it is not something that is we're
finding a a necessity
um and so they
they have it in there to discourage
because there are other options
um and that ends up being you know the
ultimate decision ends up being in the
the hands of the owner
um and the veterinarian
any other questions uh representative
coulon
thank you madam chair and thank you for
your testimony today would you say that
education on this issue might be
potentially more effective than
legislation which potentially
criminalizes
veterinarians and other people
I think education has already shown to
be effective in her tailing decline
um
veterinarians are already practicing
client education in in such a way and so
creating a law that criminalizes
veterinarians in this particular build
without specifically saying
veterinarians you know we are still
targeting veterinarians specifically in
this Bill thank you the point of
clarification sure the the bill if I'm
correct is not about a criminal penalty
correct it is uh it is a symbol I just
want us to be clear on
um
that we are not talking about
criminalization in a technical sense
that this is a civil violation yes thank
you madam chair but clarification you do
have the analysis it says Bill creates a
criminal penalty for decline cats so if
the analysis doesn't match the bill
representative come to our question
thank you very much Madam chair and
thank you for taking my question
um you mentioned that you have 400 uh
members of the New Hampshire
a VMA
now we also have corporate uh clinics
throughout the state are those
veterinarians also a member of the New
Hampshire VMA
not necessarily
follow up thank you thank you madam
chair
um and how many of those veterinarians
do those corporations employ would you
in in your estimation
um I would say most of the multi-doctor
practices here in the state are
corporate owned as a general statement
the way that
the membership
you pay for your membership and so most
of the benefits packages for these
corporations include a
amount of money that you spend on your
continuing education your membership
dues association dues and such and so it
is up to the individual veterinarian
what they spend that money on so in a
corporate practice not all veterinarians
maybe avma members not all all
veterinarians maybe New Hampshire VMA
members it's it's their personal
decision
oh one more follow-up thank you madam
chair thank you madam chair and thank
you again
um do you know
um I think we talked about how many
veterinarians were with the corporate
practice how many
companies are involved in corporate
practices in the New Hampshire
um or what are the major ones how many
major that you know of the major ones
that I know of
um are the ones that have the major
signage so a VCA hospital will have VCA
whatever Banfield will have their
corporation but we do have a structure
in veterinary medicine here in the state
that
um
they're more like silent corporations so
your Veterinary practice may be a
corporate Veterinary practice but
they're retaining the name of their
private practice beforehand so XYZ
Animal Hospital might have been bought
out by a corporate but
they're the corporate management has
allowed you to keep your private name
one more thank you madam chair
so
in hearing the testimony these major
these corporations have banned the
practice of declaring is that my is that
correct could I do not work for a
corporate I work for a private practice
um if but if that's what is being said
um most corporations have standard
operating procedures in place they have
a corporate structure
um that's on the national level and you
follow that National
Corporation
thank you any other questions from the
committee
no
seeing none I want to thank you for your
testimony this afternoon thank you very
much is there anybody else would wish to
speak on this bill today because I have
no more pink cards
uh seeing none
I have the pink sheet of the blue sheet
here
which indicates uh two people in favor
of this bill of two people against
online we had 61 in favor and six
against and with that I will close the
hearing on HB 231
and our next bill will be heard at 1 30
so we will take about a 10 minute recess
so thank you
there you go
okay gang it's uh it's 1 30. I want to
call the committee back to order
I do have to wait for my clerk
everybody please take your seats
okay uh seeing as it's 1 30 and we are
supposed to be beginning our hearing on
HB 37 establishing a committee to study
best practices for companion animal
groomers
I would call this hearing to order and I
will like to introduce representative
Jim majuri to
introduce this bill to our committee
good afternoon
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee thank you so much for
your time and attention
um
so I'll read what I have here hopefully
everybody has a copy of the testimony
especially the clerk good okay thank you
chair Aaron and members of the
environment and agriculture committee
thank you for your op thank you for this
opportunity to introduce HB 37 an act
establishing a committee to study best
practices for companion animal groomers
for the record I am Jim majory
representing Rockingham District 23
which is the town of Northampton
HB 37 is a constituent-driven bill borne
out of tragedy in 2018 Northampton
resident Joanne schweppe brought her
five-year-old golden retriever Teddy
into a local groomer for routine care
nails clipped for wash dried and trimmed
ears cleaned Etc many of us have brought
our pets into groomers for the exact
same care
unfortunately Teddy never returned home
to his family he died while in the care
of the local groomer
on behalf of the swopy family and other
families around the state whose pets
have suffered the same unfortunate fate
we hope that you will find the study of
best practices for animal groomers a
worthy effort and vote HB 37 ought to
pass
this pet Groomer's bill was first
introduced to this Committee in 2019 as
HB 376 a bill to create a study
Commission
the bill was retained to DNA and amended
by replacing the large commission with a
smaller committee
the ENA committee voted on the amended
Bill excuse me the ENA committee vote on
the amended bill was 17 to 1 ought to
pass the bill was passed on the consent
calendar by the full house but
ultimately died a Cova death in 2021 HB
376 was redrafted as HB 92 and
introduced to the Commerce and consumer
affairs committee and the vote out of
Commerce was 10 to 8 itl
according to the U.S Bureau of Labor and
statistics report from May 2021 there
are approximately
1400 and 30 30 animal caretakers in New
Hampshire
most animal groomers are skilled
professionals who complete schooling
apprenticeships trade shows attend trade
shows and maintain skills through
continuing education
some groomers even go the route of
abstaining obtaining prestigious
certifications such as certified Master
groomer through groups such as the
international Society of canine cosm
canine cosmetology and the National Dog
Groomers Association of America but
since there is no standard of care or
licensing for groomers anyone can become
a groomer and open their own business
rumors clock clients can range from
three pounds to 250 pounds
animals can have long fur they can have
short fur they could have hair rather
than fur some are friendly some are not
some are blind deaf missing Limbs and
have serious medical conditions
professional animal groomers routinely
inspect their clients for skin
irritation swelling Cuts hot spots
parasites Dental irregularities dirty
anal glands and zoonotic diseases that
is diseases diseases that can spread
between people and animals yet there is
no standard of care for animal groomers
in the state of New Hampshire
by comparison the New Hampshire Board of
barbering cosmetology and ethnic ethics
I can't say the word Aesthetics thank
you it was escaping me
uh has specific regulations under RSA
313-a which are intended to and in
quotes protect the public health safety
and Welfare for those professionals and
the public and I am not suggesting that
animal groomers must be regulated
equally but the study should examine any
potential parallels to Public Health and
accountability
Teddy's tragedy and others like it
happen all too often the good news is
that they are preventable
one instance a dog was brought into a
local groomer in the summer the dog was
groomed its fur was blown dry and the
dog was left in a plastic crate
the groomer then left the building to
run an errand when the groomer returned
the dog was dead from heat exhaustion
should a groomer be allowed to leave a
client in such a condition a study May
answer this and many other many other
questions while I understand and respect
the hesitancy to create study committees
researching the interconnectivity of pet
health client responsibility and
professional accountability is a worthy
goal and one that I am sure can be
completed in a timely fashion please
find HB 37 ought to pass and we will get
you get to work thank you for your time
and attention and of course I will be
happy to take any questions and move to
Executive session to go vote this ought
to pass unanimously so thank you
that was a big laugh
[Laughter]
thank you for your testimony
um I have a question that the terrible
tragedy for of course the pet and the
pet owner in that case of Teddy and
probably you know a handful of other
some other animals as well
were their lawsuits against uh the pet
groomer as a result of this and do you
know what happened with that particular
instances
thank you madam chair for the question
it's an excellent question I can only
speak to this one case that I know that
happened with Teddy because there was no
standard for the care a lawsuit did
ensue and the question became did the
dog come in already exhausted because it
had been at the beach and it was the
summer time
had that condition if it existed been
exacerbated by being left in a crate and
blown dry
there was no lawyers could not figure
out how to answer that question so what
ultimately happened is the groomer the
groomer was forced out of business
because of the horrible negative
publicity there was absolutely no
accountability on either side we were
left with a business that well we were
left with somebody who went out of
business and no longer does what she had
been trained to do for a long time and a
dead dog so the answer to your question
is in this one instance there was an
attempt to at least get to
accountability with no resolution thank
you and I also have another question
insofar as
so
so ostensively these groomers do go for
training and education and there are
organizations that
um
that that support
these groomers and and what they do do
these organizations not have some sort
of same course of training that they
disseminate again thank you for the
question to the best of my research
no one standard exists and that I will
say may be odd to answer this way maybe
that's the right course because there is
not a single state in the Union that has
any type of Licensing and there is no
one general standard that we're going to
and if maybe that is the answer but the
question is now in these instances and I
will say there are maybe there there
were upwards of seven to eight cases
like this per year in in our state alone
it's left people with the question of
what was I supposed to do what could I
do what happened what were you supposed
to do groomer for my animal and without
that standard of care we're again left
without any answers so I have not found
that there is a standard that that can
be applied universally
thank you uh representative kantois
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I did a quick search on certification
programs for groomers
um and the cost is
pretty high for entry we're talking tens
of thousands of dollars really to be uh
to go to these uh schools which would
prohibit a lot of people that currently
are groomers from entering the field at
this time
how would you address that situation due
to the cost and the entry and and the
second question is is it seems to me
that
most people go to a groomer based on
Word of Mouth
um
so
that the market is truly working that
way and why is that not a good thing
thank you thank you for both of those
questions the the effort to become
certified
um definitely takes time effort and
money
um and and I don't disagree with that at
all in order to go into business any
business does take again those three
elements time effort and certainly uh
the money to keep that commitment and I
don't think that I I don't want to
assume in any way that there should be
any additional costs
involved or or placed on that applicant
I'll use that word
um to get the standard it I just I just
wonder if there should be a standard for
which the these these certification
organizations are operating I wonder
that and I and I can't so I don't know
that I can answer specifically
to your second question though and I'll
use me as an example
um I've been going to one groomer for
the longest time she does a great job
with my dog a new one opened in my town
I thought support the local folks and go
in
my dog came out completely differently
um and his nails were not were not done
as well and in fact he was hurt uh in
one of in one of those nails so I think
the mark of course the market regulates
itself
um so I I not not sure that I have an
answer so much that I agree with you
that that maybe that's what might have
to happen
but I think it should be studied
representative Bixby yes thank you for
taking my question so
um
you know uh one of the questions that
seems to be coming up is uh
the egg there are existing organizations
that do certification and it takes a lot
of money to uh to go through that not
every competent groomer out there has
necessarily gone through one gone
through one of these and it seems like
maybe that's the standard of your
standard of care you're talking about
could be established without having to
necessarily
buy into one of the these more expensive
programs is that something you expect to
study would your study committee would
be looking into
thank you for the the uh the question
representative and I think you bring up
an excellent point maybe the study
committee looks at just
um maybe a resolution or a result of the
study committee is that a groomer need
only be certified
by and maybe list the organizations and
not have a certain standard and because
there are there are some baseline
standards that that are out there so
that might be one of the outcomes yes
representative Sophie caitis
put on your microphone please there are
so many different breeds of dogs
and price point of dogs and standards of
grooming of dogs and I guess my question
would be
um like I'm a nurse a registered nurse
and like all nurses have to know how to
do CPR and all nurses have to know how a
special safety measures so what would
you think of something like that
something blanket in terms of you know
safety practices not necessarily like
breed specific but safety practices for
the business
I I thank you for the question I think
that would be an excellent point to
raise for this committee again I'll use
the word maybe overuse the word should
there be a baseline for which these
groomers need to meet one in which would
be automatically or or inherently
contained within their certification I
think that would be an excellent point
to raise
representative Murray thank you madam
chair uh thank you representative for
taking my question so one question that
I did have is I'm looking at the charge
of the study committee and it's quite
broad it encompasses a lot of things so
I and I guess more to representative
suffolkitis's
um
point I I'm wondering how
do you think that you will have an
adequate amount of time to delve into
that large of a subject area would it be
would it be more efficient to look at a
more narrow area like best practices and
safety measures or do you feel that the
charge is appropriate
thank you for the question
representative
um thinking on the Fly
thinking on the Fly maybe an amendment
to to try to Pare this down wouldn't be
the worst thing but I'd have to think
about that a little bit more to figure
out uh to really look at where have been
the the pros and cons in other states
and what have they found with regard to
any of the issues that we have raised
but I would not be opposed
I would not be opposed in the interest
of time to maybe finding that my word
Baseline
um I have a question in so far as
this bill mentions three members of the
House of Representatives one member of
the Senate
these these folks to me don't really
have the
um
occupational knowledge
to really look into these things as well
as perhaps members of the organizations
that do the certifications and so forth
and it almost seems to me that it would
be more effective to have
these various groups or organizations
kind of have their own study committee
to come up with
the the answers to your questions I mean
I I I I'm I'm thinking that you're
almost looking for
the wrong group of people to come up
with the answers what are your thoughts
on that thank you thank you for the
question another interesting point I I
will say with a smile if if I am
appointed to this if this does pass and
I'm appointed to it I plan on having an
open house and bringing everybody in uh
bring every party in that might be able
to lend lend information here to help us
come up with a conclusion
um but maybe that's not the right
approach maybe the approach is is if you
if I'm hearing you correctly
if I'm hearing you correctly although I
don't know how it would happen is turn
this around to the industry itself and
and try to have the industry itself come
up with that I'm just not sure how I
would do that
um but
you know maybe bad word use a hamster
wheel to you know try to figure out
which one of us is going to come up with
the standard but your your point is well
taken yeah representative Murray
um just a a point I I do think that uh
question rather Madam chair thank you
for the question
um I I understand your point about
getting stakeholders and groups of
interested parties to the table it
sounds to me like your preference for a
study committee might give you some more
flexibility versus a commission which
may be harder to convene folks
so it are you looking at a you're
looking at your preference would be a
study committee is that what I'm hearing
thank you for the question and the
answer is yes and because that was also
what I heard coming out of a Commerce
Committee last year is that a smaller
more focused group and I think chair and
Mike go to your point a smaller more
focused group might be more effective
and be able to get a report out uh by
the I think it's November timeline
rather than but might be the right point
a commission which would be extensive
and large and bring in all of those
stakeholders to be quite honest I think
the committee again to say the committee
would be inviting all of the people who
might otherwise have been on the
commission
representative nebb thank you madam
chair I think you may have just answered
the question I was going to ask but what
were the concerns of the Commerce
Committee were there other ones besides
the size of the
um commission there was one other one
which uh which I I will say that I I am
empathetic to is and that is a concern
about licensure concern about creating
another layer of government uh to do
something and I will state as a
principled point for myself I'm not
looking to add to government I'm not
looking to complicate it and certainly
do not want to add an onerous burden uh
by way of cost upward cost pressure to
anybody but that was a concern that that
level of licensure and then to to add to
that there has not been one state in the
Union had that has passed a license for
dog groomers so I think that might I
don't think that that's an answer
licensure
representative Howard
it sounds to me as if the committee that
you're suggesting might come up with
more appropriate questions to ask the
professional
um a collection of people in the
profession including maybe even the
Humane Society and and you know
advocates for pets and and animals
um so so if you were to convene this
committee it seems like it would be at
the beginning of an investigation that
would be taken to the next level
possibly with Professionals in that area
thank you for the question and and I
agree and would would hope though that
the report because we'd have to file the
report would would be would get us down
the road I I would really resist
anything that was so open-ended that we
left saying you know we've only we've
barely passed go on this but but I do I
I do agree with you representative Dotsy
um thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I S I thought I
remembered during the last hearing that
there was a professional association of
groomers or a quasi professional
association that wanted
um you know to become more active do you
remember anything like that in go in
your research
thank you for the question I don't I
remember I remember one of the witnesses
who testified
speaking to her speaking to her
involvement in specific organ in a
specific organization but I don't
remember them being there shame on me I
apologize but I will make a note to go
back into that testimony and look
without the hearing and look
representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking
partaking so
uh study committees before in the past
and one question that sometimes comes up
is why not just put it in a bill why do
why do you need to study the committee
when you could just like write a bill
yourself
I'm not saying that that's necessarily
my take but I just would like to see
what you how you respond to that
thank you for the question and and the
first the first request of me and might
have been again born out of the tragedy
was we need to license dog groomers as a
way of of imposing some control and I
was not supportive of and again born out
of tragedy because there was no
resolution to for for that one
individual and I was not supportive of
the idea of a license but said I think
we need to look at what what kind of
standard exists uh because of what
happens which is why I of what I'm
starting to hear now is
maybe a bill to create a baseline isn't
the worst idea and a really simple
baseline from which oops from which we
can springboard into health concerns but
your point again well taken
tour thank you madam chair and thank you
again for taking my question
um and I'm gonna bounce off what
something that represents dutse spoke of
we discussed the last time we heard this
bill something similar to this is that
the groomers themselves should form the
organization and come up with their own
standard of care because they're the
ones inherently
that it affects the most
[Music]
have you spoken to anyone to see if they
have done that
and
we know that like the AKC has their own
certification for people that come into
the state to groom these dogs and they
have a certain standard that they follow
have you looked at that at all
thank you for the question and the
answer to the first question is
I was asked by a person who was involved
in that who said
we would rather excuse me way is the
wrong word that person would rather have
had this come from the state to set the
standard rather than run the risk of
having a patchwork of Standards which is
why I which is why I took this approach
of of making it a little bit more broad
to figure out but once again and I think
this goes back to a question that you
asked I would not be opposed to this to
the industry setting that standard I
think for a point that was that was
brought up before a cat is different
from a dog is different from a and by
the way just kind of tangentially that
1430 organizations that take care of
pets is as is is enormously Broad and it
does not mean that that's 1430 dog
groomers or pet groomers in the state
um so maybe maybe parse or maybe a
finding how we can break up that the the
the numbers to a more manageable number
to say okay pet dog groomers need to
meet this standard cat groomers this
standard and I don't know if that can
happen I truly don't know that that can
happen but I'd be open to that idea
oh I'm forcing them to leave
oh um so just to follow up you said this
was brought you spoke with a groomer how
many groomers have
are there in the state of New Hampshire
and how many have actually asked for
this
great question and again going to BLS
for that Bureau of Labor and statistics
uh that number was broad was 1430 uh
that that's how it's broken out for oh
my gosh now I can't remember the exact
term that's listed in BLS I apologize I
can follow up with the committee on on
that exact term but that was the number
uh that was given and how many did I
speak with initially it came to me from
two individuals locally since then I
have brought it up myself uh to both of
the groomers that I go to to ask them
about what they had to do for their to
open their business and what standards
they they abide by one of which has a
wall full of certifications it's quite
amazing
representative Knapp thank you madam
chair I wonder if you have any sense of
like the growth of the grooming industry
over the last few years because it does
feel like grooming's super expensive I
can say from personal experience and
hard to get into so I feel like there's
more and more groomers popping up I
don't know if there's any data behind
that I can provide that data to you and
while I haven't committed it to memory
it is actually a growing industry
although the the average annual income
might be what we would consider to be
lower it's in you know the 20s to twenty
to fifty thousand dollars uh that these
folks are making
um but it is a growing industry in the
state and I and I will do that research
and I can send that to com the committee
uh on anything that I can find on hard
numbers
any other questions
okay
um
you know for me personally I I'm I'm
puzzled I haven't seen any rumors or
from the industry here today to they
don't like me
to ask for this uh this kind of
um
legislation
nor have I seen anything really uh on
the portal indicating that you know
people are are seeking this kind of
thing to happen and I wonder too uh if
if there would be any kind of means for
you maybe to attend one of the groomer
Expos or something and present a
workshop of some sort uh polling people
are asking people for you know what
their what their thoughts are on on
standardizing things throughout their
industry uh any comment on that I do
thank you for the question and the
thought one of the things I thought that
I would take upon myself is as I would
do at the planning board is go on a
sidewalk you know to use that to go to a
trade show
um and and see what happens there and I
and I did think taking that upon myself
but to your first point about not as
many folks being here I I had hoped I I
had reached out to the people who had
testified last time they all had prior
commitments
um so I I can't speak to anybody else I
was I was hoping the room would be full
and we'd be here until nine o'clock at
night
I don't represent him NAB
sure okay um from the opposite direction
like we had a testimony earlier from the
dog owners of the Granite State I wonder
if their what their position on
something like this would be because
people don't naturally want to say I'd
like more regulation my industry they
might if it makes them look stronger but
I wonder if a contingent of dog owner is
what they think about it well we did get
testimony from the AKC
okay
um from Stacy Ober yes
Stacy Ober
her testimony indicated that
um they are they teach uh they have
course on learning groomer and Salon
safety protocols being informed about
pet and zoonotic diseases understanding
best techniques and they
they believe in the industry's
self-regulation effort through education
so I guess they're looking to
at least the AKC is they didn't indicate
that they were for the bill or against
the bill but just basically said how
they do things
I'm sorry that's great that's that's
informative thank you any other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for
introducing the bill and and a great uh
stimulating question and answer thank
you I also called Nancy Holmes to the
microphone
good afternoon again
my name is Nancy Holmes I'm here today
from New Boston New Hampshire and I want
to support this bill for a study for um
groomer best practices what I'd love to
see happen is that the state comes up
with a best practices
type of list of things that groomers can
do to be considered somebody who's
performing to best practices as an
example I will not leave any of the
animals in my care unsupervised at any
time
doesn't mean the groomer has to be there
it might be an assistant that's there
but somebody should be watching those
animals if that have been the case with
the golden retriever somebody should
have noticed that there was something
wrong
um another one is that they would say
keep their premises clean at all times
of animal waste and hair and debris from
grooming
I know I'm pretty sure that businesses
like groomers have to meet local zoning
ordinances
some of the questions I heard I I kind
of know the answers to which is that
there are different ways people become
groomers there are schools that purport
to train you to become a groomer and run
your own business and they include
everything from running your business to
how to groom an animal
there are people who learn how to groom
because they've got animals and they
groom them themselves
a more common method is apprenticeship
where you'll see that maybe like Petco
and PetSmart and so on they'll be
groomers and then they'll be I don't
know if they call them Junior groomers
or what they call them but these are
people who come in with no real
knowledge of grooming and they start out
doing the small tasks like sweeping the
floor and you know maybe work out to
bathing an animal and then working up to
doing Trims and so on
um there used to be a lady over
Manchester who offered um an
apprenticeship ship course and I believe
she had poodles but she would offer an
apprenticeship courts to teach people
how to become rumors and how to handle
the dog safely and and so on
we also have groomers who come into this
state as part of the dog shows that take
place in the state their professional
handlers who do their own grooming and
they are being paid to do this work but
they are not part of any local
organization
and if you've ever seen the poodles at a
dog show boy know that you earn their
money doing things
but I think you kind of have to think
about all the different kinds of
groomers you've got before you go laying
out you know what you must do I think
best practices would be a better choice
rather than rules and regulations of
what you must do
um you know saying that best practice is
this and to be able to have a
certificate on your wall that says I
abide by the New Hampshire State best
practices for animal groomers you know
something like that so a person coming
in can be confident that the rumor that
they're dealing with as opposed to some
new groomer who just popped up the
groomer that they're dealing with is
somebody that
um knows what they're doing understands
what's the what uh the better ways are
of taking care of the animals in their
care another one that came up from my
mind is I uh you know as a best
practices that I will report to the
owner any health issues that I find
during the course course of grooming
so that if the animal has ear mites or a
lump or you know a cut or something like
that that would be reported back to the
owner it isn't always I haven't used Too
Many groomers over time because I uh
managed to figure out how to run a
Clipper myself and and the show dogs
that I showed actually required a
different sort of grooming than you
would get at a professional Groomer's um
business called hand stripping where you
pluck out the fur so many weeks before
the show
so it's much more complicated than what
most groomers do but I think that that's
that not having
a contact within the industry and maybe
somebody from dogs would be a good
choice to contact and and discuss this
with but I think anybody here who has a
hobby of any sort or who maybe belongs
to a group I don't care if you're a
gardener or whatever you would have a
hard time believing that somebody who
had never gardened in their life would
be able to come up with best practices
for you as a gardener I think it really
does take some internal expertise I
believe I testified last time I didn't
I'm sorry I did not look up my testimony
from before
um that there was I think at least two
organizations in the state that are
groomer organizations
um whether they survived covet or not I
don't know
um I think you will will find this is a
growing industry because just as there
are more people who adopted animals
during the coven
outbreak then so too all those animals
or a portion of those animals will need
grooming
so that the number of places to do such
things were propping up I could open a
shingle tomorrow say say I was an animal
groomer
um I wouldn't count myself a
professional animal groomer at all
I know how to groom a couple kinds but
uh on the other hand that happens too
that people who just feel they're good
with animals will do it I support a
study but I would like to see it
broadened a little bit so that you have
experts I think somebody else mentioned
that too I like to like to see experts
involved and I would love to see them
come up with not necessarily a bill or a
law or a but a best practices standard
that people can say they adhered to that
will help
owners differentiate between one groomer
and another and that wouldn't punish
anybody who's self-taught or who went to
school or who apprenticed to get where
they were going as long as they're
abiding by the best practices to give
the animals the best care and to get the
the owners back the best information
about their animals I think that would
be a good start and if down the road you
had to put in a law that would be the
next step
hopefully hopefully my rambling is okay
do you do you think that um
this best practices or or a set of
Standards from the state would be
something that would be issued by the
Department of Agriculture yeah and it
could be you could go so far as that as
for them to have to pass an inspection
for it though I can hear the state vets
screaming as I say that but you know
they inspect pet stores
they sorry they inspect pet stores to
make sure they're doing business
properly they inspect commercial
groomers I'm not commercial breeders
they inspect animal shelters
um they respond to complaints about all
of those so I I would think maybe it
could go into rules perhaps
that these are the best practices for
people in animal grooming I I'm not as
conversant with how the rules work
um so I don't know for sure I think it'd
be really nice if somebody had a list of
best practices so that I walking into a
groomer could see oh this person is not
going to leave my animal unattended at
any time during the grooming process you
know this person is has got a clean
place and they agree to keep the place
clear and there's more those are just a
couple I thought of offhand
representative
thank you madam chair thank you Nancy
for taking my question
um the AKC has a list of best practices
they already have something
in what they do listing best practices
why would we need to go through
something if it's already out there why
are we Reinventing the wheel
say maybe we could borrow some of that
wheel
because not AKC is a great organization
it's interested in dogs but if you ask
them how to
um groom a chiweenie
or a maltipoo
or a doodle you know they'd be a little
lost at that the best practices might
cover that but I would like to see that
New Hampshire
um has something that that
gives groomers guidance as to where to
go with their business
I I would think that the organizations
have those uh resp I don't know how many
people belong to them and I don't know
what they have for paperwork or whether
they're just a a group I have no I have
no idea I just know that there were a
couple in existence doesn't mean anybody
had to join them representative
suffolkitis
as a person that owns uh purebred dogs I
will say
um just in terms of offering knowledge
that the AKC is pretty much only
concerned with purebred dogs
and so all of these hybrid breeds that
are coming out and the rescue dogs and
the mutts and you know those lovable
neighborhood dogs
are completely excluded from the AKC so
it's just professional breeders that are
generally part of the AKC
representative Dotsy
uh thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question okay let's thinking
back to
um the last time we heard a bill like
this and what we're trying to do uh it
seems to me that the organism that
rumors are looking for some Direction
they want some Direction but they
probably do not have the time and energy
and probably the expertise to create
their own professional organizations so
it seems to me what would all of us
think I guess about having something up
something like this under the Department
of Agriculture
not with a licensure but with a let's
say a certificate of best practices that
you could put on your window that comes
from the Department of Agriculture
for that a groomer would pay let's say
25 a year nothing you know unreasonable
and then if there was you know some kind
of an issue that we would then have a
state agency where a consumer could then
go to that state agency and say I have a
concern with this groomer who is part of
your best practices what would you think
about something like that thank you you
just you voiced much better than I did
you know what my what my concept was is
that there would be a best practices and
a certificate to go with it and maybe an
initial inspection and then only an
inspection if there is a complaint which
is how they do most of their other
inspection deals
um like I can remember making a
complaint about a pet store because I
was there over holiday weekend and there
was no food and water for the animals
the puppies and kittens in the windows
were there with flipped over watered and
food dishes all weekend I made a
complaint they checked it out that store
got shut down actually but yes I would
think something like that and it would
give a consumer
um
I don't know I don't know if the
groomers want Direction I think maybe
they could use direction there's people
out there who are doing everything
perfectly we know this I mean this
groomers are just great
um and then there's people who maybe
didn't even think about the fact that
they needed to do you know a supervision
over animals that were had been dried by
by a podia dryer you know that people
don't think about that until something
horrible happens
and I agreed with the person early
somebody early said something about
social media and I think in the last
hearing and that's something that will
kill people if something goes wrong
right now if somebody's dog dies at a
groom or a boy that that social media or
uproar would would be deadly for that
business I think having uh best
practices to fall back on saying well I
did this and I did this and I did this
because this is the way the rules are
and you know if I miss something you
know it wasn't deliberate I was you know
following the best practices
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much and
thank you so much for listening to me I
don't see any other pink cards and
there's nobody else in the room so
I was we have a blue sheet up there
we have one in one
Channel online we're one opposed and one
in support but there's no attached
testimony or anything so
and then on the blue sheet
we've got nothing
so with that I will close the hearing on
HB 37.
okay uh
next week we have uh house session
and so we won't be meeting on that
Tuesday
but we will be meeting on the 21st
and we will have a bunch of hearings on
the epr bill which is HB 253
and then we have two landfill citing
bills
uh
my plan is to have an exec session on
the 28th
and I've only heard from one person who
said that they wouldn't not be able to
attend that
so I think we would probably go ahead
with
yeah with that exact session on the 28th
I'll have to work out details of the
time because we may want to have
we may want to have some
time in the morning for our caucus or
for the committee to get together and
perhaps
um
have a work session on one or two bills
I don't know I need to talk to
representative Bixby about that
he might require okay yeah so okay
um I mean they're not they're not early
bills they're all we all have till March
13 uh 16th to get them out
to merge them somehow
right right
representative Haskin
Brouillard Haskins
and you as well I don't did you
okay
uh
all right
who can't make the first um
representative Davis can't make the
first Tuesday of March
and the thing is is in March we're going
to start having a lot more sessions yeah
and if I mean
right
you have to come in here two or three
days in a row is is really a hardship
okay yeah okay yeah so I I guess
we can
if we can figure out
if it's three people who are going to be
we can get some substitutes
right
okay
uh representative Davis
on the 21st we are looking at I haven't
set the schedule yet but we are looking
at hearing the epr bill which is HB 253
uh and then the two landfill citing
bills in the afternoon HB 56 and hb602
um yeah we would probably I in the
afternoon of the 21st I'd want to have
some sort of uh Republican caucus so we
can talk about everything that we've
heard
you might want to do the same
I don't know
um so that's kind of what's uh ahead of
us I don't know anybody else have any
questions or concerns or comments
nope
I know representative Brouillard has a
baby on the way and we want to
congratulate him
get all the sleep you can right then
all right so I guess we're done for
today and I would like to spend some
time with representative Bixby and just
go over uh what we can plan on so I can
give it to our new administrator okay
all right we're all set then thank you
very much everybody I appreciate all
your time and diligence
definitely so I'm going to sleep my
stuff here yeah I'll be here anyway I'm
not going anywhere yet
[Music]